dive into the world of python web
scraping with this scrapey course for
beginners learn to create scrapey
spiders crawl websites clean and save
data avoid getting blocked and deploy
your scraper to the cloud all while
using python scrapey Joe Kearney
developed this course he is an expert in
web scraping and he's the co-founder of
scrape Ops hey everyone welcome to the
free code campus crepey beginners course
my name is Joe I'm a co-founder at
scrape UPS a platform that gives
developers the tooling they need to
monitor schedule and run their web
scrapers also the co-founder of the
Python scrapey Playbook a complete
collection of guides and tutorials that
teaches you everything you need to know
to become a scrapey developer in this
free code Camp scrapey course we're
going to take you from complete scrapey
beginner to being able to build deploy
and scale your own scrapey spiders so
you can scrape the data you need you can
find the code and written guides for
this course over at the python scrapey
Playbook book free code Camp course page
so you can easily follow along with this
video
the link will be in the description
we've broken this course down into 13
Parts which cover all the scrapey basics
you need to go from never having used
scraping before to being a competent
Scrappy developer if you want to dive
deeper into any of these topics then
check out the python scrapey Playbook
itself or the scrape Ops YouTube channel
which is linked in the description
here you will find guides that dive
deeper into the topics we've discussed
in this course and cover some more
advanced grippy topics too such as
scraping Dynamic websites and scaling
your web scrapers using redis
so what is scrapey so I think the best
little summary for that is directly on
the scrapey.org website so scrapey is an
open source and collaborative framework
for extracting the data you need from
websites in a fast simple yet extensible
way
so it's an open source framework that
anyone can use with python and it makes
scraping websites much much easier
so it helps you do things like retrieve
a Pages HTML parse and then process the
data and then store that data in the
file formats you want and in the
location that you want
so that's what scrapey is so now the
next question you probably have is well
why should we choose scraping what does
scraping have to offer over anything
else
so some of you might have already done a
bit of scraping with python and you
might have used things like just
straight python requests to request the
page and then get the response and then
you might have parsed that response
using something like beautiful soup
which helps you parse HTML so this is
perfect if you're doing just very simple
scraping and you just want to scrape a
couple of pages of a website or you just
have something like a one-off site that
you want to scrape
by all means use something like python
requests and beautiful soup if you're
looking to do anything
from small medium to large scale it's
much better to use something like
scrapey because it comes with a load of
features built in that you don't have to
worry about so it helps you do things
such as data extraction from the HTML
using CSS selectors you can do
automatic data formatting so it'll
format the data you scraped into things
like CSV Json XML and many other formats
you can save the stuff directly into
things like S3 buckets onto your local
machine
and use middlewares to save the data
into databases so so much of that is
already taken care for you so what else
does that have that you don't have to
worry about automatic retrace for
example if you look for a page and the
page comes back with an error it'll Auto
retry it for you and you don't even have
to worry about all the logic that goes
into things like Auto retrace it looks
after
concurrency so you can scrape from one
page all the way up to thousands of
pages at the exact same time using the
same piece of code
so with all this stuff
so much is taken off your plate that you
can just focus on doing what you want to
do which is okay this is the data I want
from the website and this is the format
that I want to save it into
and the other great thing the fact that
scrapey is an open sourced framework
means that there's many thousands of
developers all over the world who've
made great plugins and extensions for it
almost every single kind of question we
might have is probably already answered
so it's very easy to find the questions
and answers online and things like stack
Overflow for the use cases you'll be
going through and it makes it very easy
if you don't find the question just ask
another one
so I would really recommend scrapey if
you're looking to do anything that is
more than Justice very very very simple
use case so if you're looking to scrape
any kind of website scrapey would be the
place to start off your scripting
Journey
okay so this course will be delivered
through video of course which you're
watching right now but along with the
video we have an accompanying article
that goes with each section
so for example part two we have a full
article here with all the commands you
need to run code Snippets and more
in-depth explanations
so this makes things much easier if
you're not someone who likes to watch
video and you prefer to read things and
take things step by step that way we
will also have all the codes that we use
if you want to just jump into a part
further down the line you can go and you
can download whatever part you need we
will have an accompanying git repo where
you can just download the code at that
point in time and follow on so hopefully
that should make your learning that bit
easier
okay so what we're going to cover on
this course so we're in part one now
part two will be setting up your virtual
environment and setting up scrapey on
your computer
part three we look at how to create a
scrappy project
part four creating your first scrapey
spider
and navigating through different pages
getting the HTML from the page and then
extracting what we need from the HTML
we look at crawling through multiple
Pages then how to clean the data that
you've just scraped using item pipelines
and Scrappy
then in part 7 we'll be looking at
saving the data to files and databases
and all the different ways we can do
that
part 8 looking at everything to do with
headers and user agents and how we can
use user agents and headers to bypass
certain restrictions that websites might
be putting on us when we try and collect
the data
part nine we'll be looking at rotating
proxies and proxy apis and how they can
help us bypass some of those issues
about getting blocked
part 10 we'll be looking at deploying
and scheduling our spiders using
scrapeyd so when we want to run a spider
on a regular basis we want to have
something set up that we don't have to
worry about and kick off manually but
that will be programmatically run on a
daily basis hourly basis every 10
minutes or whatever so we look at
everything to do with that in Parts 10
11 and 12 and we're looking at the
different options that are out there in
terms of the free options open source
options paid options
the pros and cons of those options that
we have and then that brings us to our
recap at the end which is part 13. and
part 13 we'll just go through everything
we've learned and recap and talk about
what there is left to do if you want to
take your scripting to the next level
so I think that's everything I wanted to
talk about and we will see you in part
two
so in part two of this course we're
going to be looking at how to install
python
setting up your price in Virtual
environment on Mac Windows analytics and
then finally how to install scraping
okay so let's get started with that
so first things first how to install
python so it's fairly easy the first
thing we want to do is we want to just
go to
python.org
go to the downloads section
and then you can click the download
python 3.11 or whatever version it will
be
when you're looking at it so obviously
I'm doing it I'm on the Mac so it
automatically detects that and it
automatically proposes that I download
the version for Mac OS you guys if
you're on Windows you'd be wanting to
download the latest version for Windows
so go ahead do that if you don't already
have python
we can quickly check if you do have
python by going to your terminal or
Powershell
so open that up
and then I'm just going to open one up
quickly here in Visual Studio code
and what you just want to do then is
just type in Python
and
dash dash version
and as you can see here python version
3.9 is installed for me so I don't need
to go under loaders because I know it's
already installed
so go ahead and check if you have python
installed if you do have it installed
you can move on to the next section and
if you don't just go ahead download
Python and install it
okay so the next thing we want to do is
install pip if it's not already
installed so pip is just a package
manager for python so we can download
third-party packages for our python
project
so what we do again we just check is it
installed so it's just pip
version again
and as I can see I have Pip version 22
installed here
so if you don't have it installed
we link to it in the documentation in
the article that we have for this and in
the video as well
so to install pip
you go to
pip.pypa.io and go to installation and
they have supported methods for
installing on Linux Mac OS and windows
and to give you the commands you need to
run
once you have a python installed to
install pip so it's very
self-explanatory and very easy to do all
you need to do is copy this line and
paste it into your terminal and hit
enter so if I do it here it will
just
tell me that I already have it installed
so as you can see it says requirement
already satisfied
pip in and then it gives the path
so we have Pip installed and the next
part is we want to install a virtual
environment
so VNV which comes with Python 3 the
latest version of python will already be
installed if you have python 3.3 and
above
if you have a lower version of python
you might need to install the VNS
manually and if you're on Windows you
may need to
install it manually as well so to do
that you just pip install virtual ends
if you're on Windows
and I'll do that right now
pip install virtual ends
and that will go ahead and install
virtual end for you
if you're on Mac you don't need to do
this
or if you're on Ubuntu you more than
likely won't need to do this either
so we have python installed we have Pip
installed we have virtual lens rvm
installed so the next thing we can go
ahead and do is actually create our
virtual environment
so a virtual environment is just think
of it as a folder that sits on top of
python where you can add all these
third-party libraries and modules and
they'll only be specific to the project
you're currently running because what
can happen is if you've got multiple
python projects you can also often have
multiple of the same packages but
different versions to run your code and
you don't want if you for example
upgrade some third-party package that it
breaks one of your other projects
because one of your other projects
needed an older version of that
third-party package so by using virtual
environments it just means that each
project you have
the third party libraries you installed
are specific to that project
so let's go ahead now and we'll just do
python
minus n
and we're going to call the folder that
we want VM also
I just want to make sure I'm in the
correct
um folder so I've just made a part two
folder with nothing in it as you can see
and I'm just going to
to thought no minus m
v n f the end
so that's gone ahead and let's create
this VN folder with
these
items in it here and it's installed
correctly
if you're on Windows you're just going
to be using the virtual end command
instead
okay so now that we have our virtual
environment installed
and you can see it here we want to just
activate it so that any third-party
package we installed after this will
also be installed into this VN folder so
to do that we just type in source
and then VM bin activate
so then you can see it's activated
because we have the folder name VNV in
Brackets
here
so that means anything we installed from
now on using the package installer pip
will be installed into this folder and
be specific only to this project
so we can go ahead now and install
scrapey
so we just do pip
install
scrapey
and you can also get this command from
the scrapey website itself as you can
see pip install scrapey will install the
latest version of scrapey 2.7.1
so I'm just going ahead and hit enter
and as you can see it's downloading
everything it needs for scrape B to run
so depending on your connection and your
computer it can take a minute or two
okay
so that's installed correctly as far as
I know
check it's installed correctly we can
just run
scrapey
and
it should give us a list of commands so
if you see this output here where it's
lists the available commands you know
that scrapey is installed correctly as
you can see from this line here scrapey
has detected that there's no scrapey
project created yet so it just says no
active project
so that's going to be the next step in
part three is setting up our scrippy
project
so let's get going into part three
so in part three we're going to be
looking at how to create a scrappy
project using scrapey
then we're going to have an overview
look at the project files that are
generated when you create a new project
and then after that we're going to go
into detail on all the different parts
of a scrapey project so that entails
scrapey spiders items item pipelines
it's created middlewares and settings
so part three is really going to be a
kind of a theory heavy part of this
course so if you already know a bit of
python this is probably going to be a
lot more interesting than if you don't
so you can feel free to dip around and
and have a look at what parts of this
would be most interesting to you we also
have an article that goes along with
this that might be a bit easier to
digest
so let's get going and create our
project so to do that I've got a folder
here part three and inside that folder
I've got just the full project we're
going to go through in a second and I've
got my virtual environment that I've
already activated
so you guys if you've followed on from
part two you should have already
activated your virtual environment and
you should already have scrapey
installed
so if you don't have that done just hop
back to part two and make sure scrape is
installed and your virtual environment
is activated okay so now we can go ahead
and
use the scrapey start project command to
create our new project
so it's just simply scrapey space start
project space and then the name of your
project we're going to call this one
book scraper because we're going to be
scraping a site with books in it
so if I hit enter
it's gone ahead and created a new folder
here book scraper you can see and if I
do an LS you can see book scraper is
there as well if
and if we go into
book scraper itself we can see we have
book scraper and scrapey.cfg so I'm just
going to open up
the folder here and we can see inside of
that we have several different files and
folders so first off we have our spiders
folder
that at the moment has no spiders in it
but we'll be doing that in part four
we'll be generating spiders that go in
there then we have items middlewares
pipelines and settings
so your basic scrapery project will
contain these parts now you don't have
to use items you don't have to create
middlewares you don't have to touch
Pipelines
but you will always have a spider
so you can think of items middlewares
and pipelines are optional but we will
be using them because
if you're scraping anything more than
just one page it becomes a lot easier
just to use the pipelines items in
middlewares and instead of trying to
have everything custom made in a spider
Okay so the next thing we're going to
quickly look at is a fully
fleshed out spider
so just to give you an idea of what
would go into these things like what is
in items what does middlewares mean what
we put in pipelines that's going to go
through some code and give you an
example
so don't be too scared if you don't
understand any of this stuff right now
we're going to be going through all of
it in Parts four five six seven eight
so we start off with our spider
so in here in our spiders folder there's
just a simple spider called book Spider
it's just a simple class it's got a name
it's got some functions there
and inside it has things like items
which link into our items.py file here
as we can see we're importing it
and this is just a basic spider so I'll
just give you a quick overview of what
it does once you run the spider it goes
to start requests and it puts this URL
into this URL variable and then it
returns scraping that request function
with the URL and once the request comes
back from the page with the HTML in it
it goes to the next function which is to
find in
the parse function
so this parse function then
lets us use the response that contains
the HTML and we can then manipulate this
HTML and extract the things that we want
such as the title category description
price once we've got those those pieces
of data are put into our book item and
that is then returned to us in the
console are if you've got other things
set up such as feeds into a file
so that might all be completely
overwhelming for you but don't worry
we're going to be going through all of
this in extreme detail and showing you
exactly how to do everything that is
already here this is just to give you an
idea of what's what
Okay so
you might have seen this book item that
I mentioned so book items
then links into our items.py file and in
that file we just describe
how we want the item to be set up so we
want our book should contain title
category description and price
so then using this we can then use this
book item both in our spiders when we
fill the book item with the different
pieces of data and return it and also in
our Pipelines
so in our Pipelines
we have a simple
test one set up here which goes through
mimicking how you would
then get the data that is returned
um in the book Spider
this book item with all the details and
it goes through how it would save the
item in a database so think of it we
extract the data The Next Step would be
to push the data into the item and then
to put the item into a database
so Pipelines
are what happens once you've extracted
and you're yielding returning the data
from your spider
so here we have for example process item
it's fairly self-explanatory it takes
the item
with the title the category description
and it inserts it into our books
database table
so that's what
gets put into items and item Pipelines
again this could be all very confusing
for you if you know a bit of python
hopefully it shouldn't be too confusing
but we'll be going into it in a lot more
detail later on okay so
then we have our middlewares
so
middlewares are where you can
get into the nitty-gritty of
how you want the spider to operate
so it gives you control over lots of
different things such as
timing out requests how long you want
the request to go on for what headers
you want to send when you make a request
what user agents should be used when you
make a request if you want to do things
like multiple retries you can mess
around with that in the middlewares
section and as you can see it comes with
several kind of defaults that are there
that you can either update to what you
want or you can create your own ones
that go in here too
so you also have managing cookies
caches there's everything like that
would be dealt with in your middlewares
now there's two types of middlewares
there is downloader middlewares and
spider middlewares
most of what we'd be doing would
probably go into the downloader
middlewares
but spider middlewares can also do
things such as adding or removing
requests or items handling different
exceptions that crop up if there's an
error with your spider handling things
like that
so all these middlewares go in the
middlewares.py file and then last of all
we have our settings
so settings is fairly self-explanatory
it's where you
put all your settings so you've got
basic things like do we obey our
robots.txt file when initial request is
made to a website do we check that first
and if it says don't scrape this site do
we obey that yes or no it said here the
number of concurrent requests we make so
if we're scraping a website do we send
one request at a time or do we send 10
or 100 requests at a time that's also
set here
so everything to do with how your spider
and crawling operates will be either
enabled or disabled in this settings.py
file now we also have going back to what
we were talking about our middlewares we
have our spider middlewares
as you can see here and our downloader
middlewares as you can see here so this
is where you can if you create a new
middleware so this one directly links to
the book scraper spider middleware that
is
right here
so you need to make sure if you create a
new middleware that you then enable it
in settings also
and also Verizon pipelines that's also
where you need to enable if you create a
new item pipeline that it is enabled in
here also
okay so I think we've gone through the
basics of a full scrapey project and
what's contained in there we've gone
through what's usually in a spider gone
through items and item pipelines how
they can process the data once we've
scraped the data from a page and then
we've looked at middlewares and how in
settings we can turn everything on or
off
so I think that's everything we wanted
to cover in this part now again don't be
too overwhelmed by this
it does get a lot easier trust me so
stick with it and in part four we'll be
creating our first spider and extracting
some data from a web page
in part four of our scrapey beginners
course we're going to look at how to
create a scrapey spider
using the Scrapy shell to find the CSS
selectors we need
using those CSS selectors in our spider
to extract the data we want from the
page and then finally we're going to get
our spider to go through multiple pages
and extract data from multiple pages
so let's get going so I've got my
terminal open here I've already
activated my virtual environment I'm
continuing on from part three so if
you're just joining us here make sure
you already have everything set up as we
have done in part three
I want to go all the way down into my
spider's folder so at the moment it's
empty it's just got an init.py file in
it so we want to go down the level and
down into the spiders so now I'm in my
spiders folder and I can see there's
just a new py there so in this spider's
folder I'm going to run
this command scrapey gen spider
the name of my spider which I'm going to
call book spider and then
the URL of the website that we're going
to be scraping and in this case it's
going to be
the books.2 scrape.com site which is a
site that is there for people to
practice their scraping up
so
if you go ahead and go down to your
spiders folder and type this command
into your terminal
and hit enter
scrapey will then create this spider as
you can see here created spider book
Spider using template basic in module
and then it gives this so if we check
that out now we can see that book
spider.py is there and if I open this up
in my vs code we can see it created
book Spider here so
this is just a very very basic spider
we'll be adding a lot more to this
but we'll just go through a few bits of
what were generated here so obviously
the name of our spider is book Spider so
when we do Scrapy crawl to actually kick
the spider off using scrapey we'll be
doing scrapey crawl book Spider
the allow domains list
is books.2script.com
this is important because later on when
we're going to be doing crawling our
spider is going to be going through
multiple different links
and having this allowed domains here
listing only the domain we want to
scrape prevents our spider from going
off and scraping hundreds of different
websites across the internet because as
you can imagine URLs link from one page
to another and sometimes a website might
link to an outside website
and in this case you would not want your
spider to start crawling and scraping
the entire internet
so that's why we have allowed domains
here next we have start URLs so this is
usually just the first URL that the
spider starts scraping but you can
actually have multiple URLs here as well
for it to go through one after the other
then we have our parse function our
parse function is
the function that gets called once the
response comes back so we'll be filling
this parse function with all the
different pieces we want to extract the
data from the page itself
Okay so we've gone through the basics of
this generated spider the next thing
we're going to do is we're going to use
the scrapey shell
to find the CSS selectors
we want to get the data from the page
so what I mean by CSS selectors for
those of you who aren't familiar so
first of all if you just open your
developer tools
you can do this by right clicking in
Chrome or Safari or Firefox and it's
usually inspect or sometimes it's called
developer tools
so you do that and this comes up here if
you go to the elements tab you'll see
then all the makeup of the page in HTML
and CSS
so here for example we've got a H3 tag
and an a tag for links and this is the
link to the page of this book here
so we'll be looking now at how we can
actually pick out these tags so that
scrapey knows which pieces of data we
want to extract from the page itself
okay so let's just go back to our
terminal and just to make using the
Scrapy shell a little bit easier we're
going to do
just a pip install and then I python
which just is a different shell would
help if I spelled it correctly this is
just a different shell which is a bit
easier to read so I just did pip install
IPython and then to activate this we
want to go to settings
and
we I know we want to go to sorry not
settings this
scrapey.cfg
and we're going to add
the shell as a separate line here so
now that that's done I can close Dash
and we can run scrapey shell
Scrappy shell then gives us this so what
we want to do now we have scrape your
shell open is as you can see we've got a
list of the commands that it gives us
that are available so we can do
useful shortcuts fetch which is the
command that we're going to be using
so this fetches a URL and updates
the
local objects
so we'll just run this fetch command now
and I'll show you exactly what I mean
so we want to fetch this books to
scrape.com
so I'm just going to paste in
this URL here and
it's going to go off it's going to fetch
this and it's going to put the resulting
HTML everything in here that we see
into a variable inside in the scrapey
Shell so we can access it and run
different commands on it
so enables us to kind of practice the
code we want to then put into our spider
so what we want to do is it put
everything in from the page into this
response
variables so now we can just do
response.css and
let's say we're going to look for
something specific on the page so what
we can do is move our Mouse over these
different
tags on the page we can see article
contains
one
book on the page so we can just say okay
give me article
and we'll just have the class name in as
well so any class name
needs to have just dot in front of it
when we're referring to it like this
so that has given us
all the different books that are on the
page
now let's say we want to just get the
first book we can just do this
with a guess and it's giving us just the
HTML that is
for that first book if we want to then
put all the books into a different
variable so we can run some other
commands on them within the scrapey
shell we can do something like
books is equal to
response.cssarticle dot product pod
if we do that it's after putting all the
different books into this books variable
so then if we run Len
on books then in Python gets us the
length
so it gives us that there's 20 books if
we go back to our page
we can indeed see there is 20 books so
there's four in each Road there's one
two three four five rows showing one of
20 so that's correct
Okay so
for the purposes of this part four we're
going to extract the name of the book
the price of the book and the URL so we
can actually go in and get further
details later
so the name the price and the URL
so now that we've got our books what we
can do is
we can put the first book
of the list of books
so we'll make a new variable called book
and we'll say that's equal to
equal to books
and the first item in the list of books
that we have
so now if I do
book.css
and then
I go back and okay we want to get the
the title of the book here so I can see
from this that we've got a H3 tag and
we've got an A tag and I want the text
that is within this a tag here so I'm
going to do H3 and a
and that should get me the text that I'm
looking for the title of the book
so go back here
and I do H3 a and then we just need a
little bit extra which is just this text
and I do get
that gets me exactly what I was looking
for which is a light in the dot dot dot
this corresponds exactly to this so I've
got the title of my book
next I want to get the price of my book
so I'm going to just remove these two
pieces here
and I'm going to inspect the price
okay so if we look at dot product price
and then dot price underscore color
should give us the price so let's do
that now so
that's
Dash product price
color let's try and run that
okay it didn't
exactly what I I know because I S I did
an extra double dot there you go so that
got us exactly the price we're looking
for and finally we want to get the URL
so the URL
is
interesting because it's also part of
this h3a tag but we want instead of the
text within it we want this href
attribute here which contains the part
of the link to more information on the
actual
book itself so if we open this up in a
new tab we'll see the full page that
we're looking for and here you can see
full project description and lots more
details there
Okay so
we still want to do
H3 and a
but instead of text we're going to say
a
a trib
e hatred that gives us our href
attributes
that was contained in this a tag that we
were looking at a second ago so using
the Scrapy shell we've managed to see
how we can use the CSS selectors to
extract the title the price and the URL
for one book
so now that we know that we can add
these into our parse function
and we can also Loop through all that
list of books and get all the details
for the 20 books that are on the page
Okay so
let's start adding things to our parse
function so first I'm just going to add
in what we initially had to get all the
books
that were there and that is
books equals to response dot CSS article
and then product underscore pod so we
had that
up
here
so I'm just taking this line here that
we used in our Scrapy shell and I'm
putting it in to our parse
function okay the next thing we want to
do is we're just going to Loop through
it so we just want
four book in books
and then we are going to type yield
so yield is like return
and then what we want is scrapey to
return to us is going to be the name the
price and URL
so we'll start with the name and then
we're going to go up to where we
got our text and we're going to use this
exact
piece here
and then we're going to get our price
and we're going to go to where we got
our price
and then
last of all our URL
and for that we have our
href attributes
okay
now that we have that
we should be able to go ahead and run
our spider and see what happens so first
let's exit our scrapey Shell by typing
exit
and then we might need to go up a level
to our
book scraper folder and we should be
able to run
scrapey crawl
book Spider which is the name of our
spider
so
if that goes according to plan
we should see item script count of 20
there are the 20 books on the page and
you can see what was returned here the
name there is a book name a price there
is a price and URL there's the URL and
if we just scroll up we can see that the
20 books that were on the page all the
data was script and output to our
terminal so that worked exactly how we
wanted it to work
now as you've seen we have multiple
Pages there's not just this one page of
20 books there is actually a lot more
than that so we're going to look at how
we can go to the next page if there is
one
and then scrape all the books on the
next page and then keep looping through
all the pages of books until there are
no more pages of books to scrape
so
as you can see here we have a next page
at the bottom of every
page of books so if we click the next
page button it goes to catalog
page2.html and then we have a new page
of 20 different books and as you can see
it's going through all the different
pages page three and there's a previous
there as well to go back a page so
we're going to want
scrapey to bring us to page Dash three
our
page-4.html if there is another one to
scrape
so we're going to go back and we're
going to do scrape your shell again
to open our shell we're going to again
roll in our fetch command
to fetch
our website URL and then we are going to
try and get the link so to do that we're
going to inspect
the next button and as we can see here
it's in An Li tag and then it's got a
class name of next and then within that
we want the
link which is contained in this href
attribute and that's contained in an a
tag for links
so let's see if we can get that now
using our scripture
so we do response.css and then
allies dot next so Ally for the Ally tag
dot next for the class name and then a
and then we want the href attribute
so
so that c can me to Dash
and that gives us exactly our catalog
forward slash page 2.html which
corresponds to well this was not the
exact one we're looking at we're looking
at page one
so I can just remove that
and go down here and this one should
have catalog for slash page 2.html
and that corresponds to this
so now that we know how we can get the
next page we can just
put in under our Loop
we're just going to paste what we had
here to get our
link
and we're just going to do next
page is equal to
and this is going to contain our next
page link so
the next thing we need to check for is
if we get to the last page
there's going to be no more next page
link so that's how we can know
when we've reached the end
so we can check that by
going to page 50.
so if I
type in page
50 and
go to the bottom I should see that there
is no more next button there's a
previous button but there's no next
button so I've reached the end so that's
what our test is going to be we're going
to put in an if statement and we're
going to say if the next page URL is not
none
then we know there's another page so we
can continue going until there is no
more pages left to scrape
so let's add that in now okay we're just
going to do if
next page is not none
and then
next page
URL is equal to
and here we're going to create the full
URL because next page doesn't contain
the full URL it's only
a relative URL
so we need to get
this part of the URL plus the catalog
forward slash whatever the next part of
the pages
so
let's add that in
save that
and then the important part is we need
to do
yield
response dot follow
next page URL
and then call back
is equal to self Dot
parse
okay
so what this does is it obviously
creates our next page URL
and then we tell scrapey to
go to this next page URL using
response.follow and the Callback is the
function that's going to get executed
once the response comes back from the
URL that we've gone to
so once we get the response from that
URL it's going to kick off self.parse
and self.parse is this function again so
it's going to keep going through and
keep going through and keep going
through and calling itself until there
is no more pages and then in that case
it's going to stop
let's try and run that now so let's exit
out of our scrapey shell and let's just
do a scrapey crawl again
scrape your crawl and book Spider
and see what we get
okay
so with an item script count of 40
so it scraped four pages but obviously
four pages is not 50 pages
so there's a bit of a bug here which
we're going to have to get to the bottom
of let's start looking at the next page
URL because that's obviously where it's
going wrong if it's only finding four
pages there must be an issue with the
URL here so if we go back and we again
inspect the element so here we can see
it's page-50.html
and
I think we had
and here it's 49 but then if we were on
the initial page
and we check here it's got catalog
forward slash page two
so sometimes it's got just page Dash 2
and sometimes it's got the catalog in t
href so that's obviously why it only
scraped
four pages so the fifth page only has
page five so we're gonna have to just
modify our next page and if statement
here
just to check that we have catalog in
the href if we do then we do a slightly
different next page URL than if we don't
so let's just add that in now so if the
catalog
forward slash is in next page
then the next page URL is going to just
be what we currently have
and but if it's not we want an else
and we're going to say
add in
the next page URL
but we're going to add in catalog here
so this should ensure that the next page
URL is correct so if it contains catalog
we don't need to have catalog
in this part if it doesn't contain
catalog we do have to have it and then
that should make the correct URL
so hopefully that's fixed that bug so
let's try run the scripty crawl one more
time
okay so this seems to be going through a
lot more pages
which is a good sign
and let's give it another
minute or two to finish up
and we can see the total item counts at
the end and the total page of script so
this is kind of the process that you
have to do when you are creating a
spider to scrape data there'll be small
bugs like this that pop up and you need
to do a small bit of detective work to
find out why your spider is failing at
certain parts or not able to
extract certain pieces of data from the
page
so we can see here we have
response received count to 51
I sub scraped count of a thousand
so
if we go back
there is a thousand results so it
scraped all the books that we were
looking for that's pretty much
everything we wanted to cover in this
part four in part five we're going to go
through and each book we're going to
click into the book and then we're going
to extract more product data from the
product page itself
so right now we're just kind of doing
the easy thing of just going through one
page one page one page just the name and
extracting just the name the URL and the
price but in real life scenarios most of
the time we want to get a lot more data
and that involves doing things like
going in clicking into the actual
product we're looking at and actually
getting more in-depth data
so we'll be looking at how we can do
that
in part five
so in part five we're going to look at
how to crawl Pages using the scrapey
spider
using CSS selectors and expats to
extract more complicated pieces of data
from Pages such as from tables
from breadcrumbs things like that and
then we're going to move on to saving
the data into certain file formats such
as CSV or Json format so let's get
started
we're continuing on from part four so if
you need to get the code for that we'll
have that available for to for you to
download and follow on at this point or
if you've got your part 4 already
completed you can just continue on from
there
so in part four we just ran our spider
and it went through and got us the
details of the Thousand books that are
on the books to scrape.com site
so the next thing we're going to be
doing is we're going to be instead of
just scraping the
URL the price and the name of the book
we're actually going to be going into
the book page itself and we're going to
be taking things such as the rating
the product description the product type
the price excluding that including that
the category that it's in such as poetry
in this case
so we're going to be looping through all
the different books looping through
every single page and getting all the
specific data for each book that is on
this site
okay
so let's go back to our Spyder code
and the first thing we're going to look
at doing is we want to start going into
each page individually and so to do that
we're going to do something that's very
similar to going to each next page URL
so we'll copy this code from the bottom
and we're going to do this for every
book in the list of books so instead of
just yielding the data we're going to be
going into the URL so we're just going
to paste that in over our yield
right here
we're going to remove the
next page non-section
we're going to move our next page URL
Pier
and we're going to have to just modify
where we get the URL for the each
individual book so if we just go back
into inspect
the elements again and check out okay so
that was H3 and a and we want the href
for that H3 a tag
so we just want h3a attribute href that
should get us
the next page
and then it should create the correct
URL for us
instead let's call of next page because
it's not the next page it's the relative
URL of the book lets us call it relative
URL
and let's just
put this
here
and
the next thing we want to do is
we want the Callback function instead of
being parse we're going to do parse book
page
so we're going to make a new function to
parse the book page individually one by
one
so let's go down here
let's do Def
passbook page
self and response
and
at the moment let's just put pass in
there so fat is going to
Loop through
instead of next page URL I'm going to
call this one
book URL
and
Okay so
the only other thing to change that is
incorrect is that obviously
we need to Loop through the list of
books so this book needs to be used and
we're going to get the book.css and
that's where we're going to get our
link from with the
this link here
so that goes to relative URL and
variable
then we make the correct book URL and
then using this book URL we yield
um
so we basically go into this
um book URL and then the response HTML
that comes back from this URL will get
parsed by the parse underscore book
underscore page function which is the
one we made down here okay so I think we
can save that for now
and next thing we want to do is start
flushing out our parse book page so what
we're going to do first is we're going
to open up our scrapey shell again like
we did in part four and we're going to
look at the different CSS selectors and
expat selectors for the different items
that we want to scrape on the book page
itself so let's click into one of the
books and we're going to see what if we
want to extract from this page
let's go back open up
our scrapey shell in our terminal again
so just Scrapy shell
and when that opens we're just going to
use our fetch function again to fetch
the full URL from one of the book pages
which in this case is just the very
first book I've picked
in the list
so
I can just put in the URL in here hit
enter that's going to go off get the
HTML of that page and stick it in the
response variable
so just like we did in part 4 we can
see what works and what doesn't work
with our CSS selectors
so let's just do
response dot CSS
and then let's inspect the page again
and just
okay so we have
product description there is an ID
and
there is a P tag underneath that
so product pay underscore page there so
that gives us the whole page so let's
just try and see what happens if we do
product on the score page
that seems to give us back the whole
page
now let's look at getting the title of
the book
for example so in this case
on this page
it's in the product underscore Main and
it's H1
so let's go ahead and just do
so Dosh
product underscore Main
H1
text
and there we have a Light in the Attic
which matches to our Title Here
so that's very simple just as we've done
before
so now let's
do something a little more complex let's
get the category up here so we have
poetry in this case
so for things that are a little bit more
complicated like this sometimes it can
be easier just to use expats instead of
CSS selectors so expats are very similar
but instead of using class names
directly the format of how we write
the expats is just a little different to
how we would use
CSS selectors so I've got one
pre-written out which I'll just paste in
here
so
paste in my XPath and that gives me
poetry so I'll just explain to you how
this gosh poetry
so it went to the UL HTML tag
it's
put in the class breadcrumb
so if we go back to the top here
we should see it's in a UL
HTML tag and the class is breadcrumb and
then we have several Li tags and then we
have an a tag within the LI tag and we
have the href
so here we can see that's where tli tag
comes into it
and then
the active class
is on the grayed out section here
so
it's then going from it's going to here
and then it's saying preceding sibling
so get me the preceding Li tag before
the one that has the active equals class
in it so it's going to here and then
it's going back one to the preceding
sibling and it's getting the text within
here
and it's doing that with
the text at the end here so as you can
see proceeding sibling Li
one
and then a and text at the end
so expats are quite similar
to CSS selectors in not every case will
you have
a class name or an ID tag on a HTML tag
so in the case of the product
description which I showed you a second
ago we'll just look at it again there is
no class name or no CSS ID on on this P
for paragraph tag here so in that case
as well we can say right go to the
product description using the expats and
then get me the following sibling that's
a P tag
so I can just show you that one so it's
go to the product description ID
get me the following sibling with the P
tag and then within that get me the text
so that's how expats work for getting
some of these Corner cases where you
might not have a simple class name or a
simple ID on the HTML tag
okay so we know how we can get the
product description and the category tag
up here
we know how we can get the price and the
title
next let's look at extracting data from
tables
so
if we inspect element again we can see
that this is all contained within a
table and this table has several rows
which have TR as the HTML tag and then
within the table row we have th and TD
and that goes the whole way down so each
row has
one more th and TD so what we can do is
we can specify okay get me all the rows
in this table and then we can say okay
we know that the product type is always
going to be the second row
so let's always look for the text that
is within the TD of the second row if we
wanted for example to see the product
type
so first we want to get all the table
rows so we're going to look at table and
then all the TRS that are in that table
if so then let's assign that to
a table underscore rows in our Scrapy
shell so if you just use table
underscore rows equals to response dot
CSS and then have table space TR within
the brackets
that will make sure that all those table
rows are within table rows we can
quickly check the length of that
that gives us seven rows and there's one
two three four five six seven rows so
now we can do something as simple as
table underscore rows
let's look at what we said the second
ago the second one the dot CSS again and
we want the TD
and we wanted the text within that
and I guess again we use get and we get
books
so again
the numbering starts at zero and then
the second one is
second line is number one and then we
look at the T D here
the TD and that gets us books
so that's how this line corresponds to
here in this table
so knowing that we can then go ahead and
get things like
the price excluding tax we can just put
in something very similar the next row
down
and that should give us the price
excluding tax
so we now can get all the data we need
from this table
and the only last thing to look at is
looking at how we can guess
the Stars
so if we just look at
inspect element we can see
we have several Stars here it has icon
star icon star
and star rating of three
so that's where we can see the number of
stars it's within this class
that they've written three so we need to
do something slightly different for this
so first off we're going to get
the star region
so we're going to do
response.css then p
star rating for the class and then we're
going to ask for the attribute of class
so this is the attribute the attribute
name is class and then it should give us
our three that we're looking for
so let's just do that now
so
response
dot CSS P star rating attribute class
and that gives us star rating of three
so using our scrippy shell
we've looked at how we can get all the
different pieces of data from the page
so let's start filling that into our
parse book page function here
so we can actually get all the book data
to be scraped correctly okay so let's
just exit
out of our Scrappy show
and let's first just get the table rows
so
table rolls are going to be equals to
response
dot CSS
and then we're gonna have
what we had up here
where you can see table rows is table TR
so table TR is a table rows and we can
work with that now to fill in the rest
of the details so we want to remove pass
and then we're just going to do yield
and we're going to have our details
inside here so let's start off with the
URL
that's easy because we can just use
the
response
sponsor URL
so the URL of the page is contained
within this response
object then let's get the title
so we had Dash up here
here
so
can just copy this directly
don't forget to add
commas at the end
and let's get the product type the price
excluding tax including tax the tax
so these are all to do with the table
so
we're going to be doing table row
one for the second row and then TD text
get for the product type and so on for
the price excluding tax and including
tax as you can see
price excluding tax price including tax
they're all one after the other here so
all we're doing is incrementing the
number here
and the tax itself
and we might as well add in the
availability and the number of reviews
as well
since that's just a continuation of the
same thing
so
add those two in
we'll add in the Stars by
doing this so let's copy
we have them here
and we'll just call that
Stars
and we can just paste that directly
and let's also get the category and the
description like we had a second ago
so category
or with that using the expats so that
was this guy here
let's just
paste Dash let me have to just get it
all in the same line
perfect and
let's get the description
okay and we just want
this XPath that we were using earlier in
our Scrapy shell as well
again just making sure that we
have it all in the same line and
that we add in our commas finally the
only thing missing is the price
and we can do that by getting the
response
and then
dot CSS P dot price color and then the
text from that
so the price is up here
and that's the class of price color
within the P tag
so if we save all that that should be
everything we need to parse the
individual book pages and the thing
that's just missing here
is the next page which we just need to
add back in we deleted that earlier by
mistake
so that's how we get the next page URL
okay so everything else looks correct so
just a quick recap
the spider is going to kick off go to
this start URL
the response that comes back the first
time around
we'll go into this parse function
this parse function then we get all the
books on the main page
so that is starting with all these
different books here
then the next thing that happens is we
get the relative URL and we turn that
into the book URL we do that by getting
each of these URLs here
once we get the first books URL we then
go into that book page
so what happens is the code basically
goes in here it's then
goes to the Callback function which is
parse book page down here it goes gets
all these details here that we specified
and then is
Loops to the next book on the page
because this so it comes back out
here and then Loops back up to the start
and goes to the second book on the page
goes Clicks in gets the data
comes back does the third book in the
page so Loops through all the books on
the pages keeps getting all the data for
each book and then it goes to the next
page
and then once all the pages are done it
finishes so if we've done everything
correctly we should be able to
now run our spider and see does that
work
so let's try and do a scrapey crawl
the thing we're going to do that's
slightly different this time is we're
going to have the output go to a file so
instead of having the output come into
just our terminal we're going to also
get it to save to a file so we do this
by doing minus all uh our Dash o and
then we're just going to call this book
data and we'll do two
um CSV
CSV so CSV file formats can be opened in
Excel or can be put into you know Google
Sheets and different applications like
that so it's CS face just stands for
comma separated values
so if we run that hopefully there's no
issues
and as you can see there's book data.csv
here
you can open that and we can see we have
nodes of data
so all the stuff that we were looking
for
price description
everything else seems to be there
so I'm just going to stop that now
before it gets the end because that
seemed like it's working correctly it
was already on page 15 here let's see
okay and I'll run that one more time
except this time
and do it in instead of book data.csv
we're going to get her to Output to Json
so I'm just going to
delete that one and get it to a push to
Json format instead
Json format can just be a bit easier to
read and if you're doing further coding
it can be easier to parse as well
so if we opening up as you can see it
has all the data nicely formatted the
title price including tax availability
the number of reviews all the data is
all there
so that's working nicely obviously it's
going to take a minute or two to scrape
all a thousand books
but I think that's everything we wanted
to go through in part five
in part six we're just going to be
looking at how we can use items and item
Pipelines
to better structure and clean our data
before we start saving it into things
like a database
so it'll just put a bit more structure
on our code and it'll enable us through
things such as for example we could
change the prices from pounds to dollars
four gets saved we could you know remove
any trailing white space lots of
different examples we'll go through in
part six of how to clean up the data
okay see in part six guys
so in part six of the scrappy beginners
course we're going to be looking at
scrapey items and Scrappy Pipelines
so first off we're going to go through
what scrapey items are then we're going
to use scrapey items to structure our
existing spider a bit better then we're
going to go into what scrapey pipelines
are and what they do and then we're
going to use the scrapey pipelines to
clean our data
so let's get started
if you're continuing on from part five
you should have everything already set
up if not you can download the code from
our repo and continue on from where we
are now
so I'm presuming you already have your
book scraper project set up with your
spider set up and you've got your
environment activated
and you have screen be installed and
python installed and everything else is
running
okay so items so when you generate a
Scrapy project it generates this items
dot py file
and this is where you put your items so
items just help us Define what we want
in a block of data that we're scraping
and that were returning
so for example here you can see in our
book Spider we have no specific item
declared we're not using an item that's
been created in relationship is that py
but instead we just have a yield with
all the different pieces of data we're
extracting from the page
so that works fine but just to clean
things up and to make things a bit less
ambiguous the best thing to do is to use
the items.py and declare a specific item
in there
so let's go ahead and do that now
so I'm just going to copy and paste the
one I've already got in called book item
the book scraper item is just the
default one you can leave that there for
the moment
so book item just has everything that we
already have used in
our book Spider so URL title product
type all these different things
but instead were
declaring them specifically here so you
might say well what's the point of that
well one example is that if I
do a Miss type and reviews goes in like
this
this might then not go into my database
or might not go and be processed further
down the line
and I might not even notice it but
if I'm using an item
scraper will throw an error and say
this Norm underscore reviews with two
r's does not exist and it alert you to
the fact that there is a typo here so
that's one very good reason as to why we
will use our items
and actually Define the item first so
now that we've got the item to find
we've got our item class created let's
actually start using that
so first off we want to import that into
our spider
so we go up to the top
and we're importing book item as you can
see it brings us directly to the book
item now the next thing we want to do is
we just want to
specify
a book underscore item is equal to book
item and then we're just going to yield
book item at the bottom so instead of
yielding just start texturing there
we're going to yield book item
and then we're going to
remove
those two brackets and
we're going to say book item URL
is equal to response to the URL and so
on all the way down
so change all these into using our item
and then once that's done
we'll start looking at
item Pipelines
so let's look at the data that have been
saved into our file so this book data
dot Json was what we did in part five
that was the output from our spider that
ran
so as you can see we had things like the
URL the title so on so forth
but if you noticed
we have the price excluding tax for
example has this encoded value here so
it looks like the pound sign did not go
in correctly
so you can specify
a specific
serializer that you want to use on a
specific field
so for example if it was like the price
I've a serialized price function I can
write
and I can then use that serialize price
to stick a dollar or a parent sign in
front of the value
so for example I can stick serialized
price and I'll put it in front of the
price excluding tax
so I could just do something like
serializer
serializer is equal to
and then serialized price so that would
make
the value go in here and then have the
pen size applied to it before it gets
put into price excluding tax so that's
also a cool way that you can use items
with serializers
so I'm just going to remove that one for
now because we actually end up
processing the data from this in item
pipelines in a second anyway I just
wanted to show you how you could use
this if you didn't want to do pipelines
and you're you're only going to scrape a
small bit of data and you didn't want to
do a lot of post-processing there's no
point using pipelines and you could just
stick to using just items and have a
serializer if you needed to but if
you're going to do anything more complex
and you want to do a lot more processing
of your data you're better off using
pipelines instead of just using serial
lasers
the next thing we want to do is look at
our Pipelines
so in our pipelines again scrapey
defines a book scraper pipeline when you
create the project this is just here to
give you an idea of what you can get
started with so using pipelines you can
clean your data for example you can
remove the currency signs if you want
you could convert the price from pounds
to dollars you can format strings to
integers if you're going to save it into
a database that becomes very important
and you can do things like converting
your relative URLs to full URLs you can
validate your data check if the price is
actually a price or is it sold out and
then in that case you can you know put
in a price of zero and you can also use
the pipelines to store the data so
instead of having all the data going
into a file like we've done in part five
we could have it we could use a pipeline
to get the data to go directly into a
database
which we will be doing in future parts
of this series
so let's clean up our data a bit now
what do we need to clean well straight
away this is not good for our data this
encoded value here so we need to sort
that is another thing we need to sort
out could be the availability of the
stock so you might say okay in stock 19
available is fine but if I needed to run
a piece of code later
on this data that's not very useful
because I just want to know that there's
19 books I don't want to have this extra
text here and here and brackets so if I
just wanted availability to be 19 I
could use the pipeline to remove the in
stock and the available parts of the
string and just convert that 19 into an
integer
okay so we'll do that also and I think I
saw in some places that things like the
title had a trailing white space
are the descriptions had trailing white
space
so that's also something that we could
remove
and another thing would be changing the
category we could change the category
instead of it being Thriller with a
capital we could change that to Thriller
with lowercase
so this kind of standardization of data
before it gets saved into a file or into
a database is important especially when
you start scripting at scale and doing
larger projects
so we're just going to go through a
bunch of different processing in our
process item in our pipeline
so we will just add everything in here
and then the item will be returned
so let's start with just removing the
white space
so I'll just paste in the code I've
already got
and talk you through it okay we straight
away get our
item which gets passed in to our process
underscore item so we've got the item
available we pass it into the item
adapter
so as you can see up here useful for
handling different item types with a
single interface
with this adapter we can get all the
field names and then we can Loop through
using our for loop loop through all the
field names
and if it's
not the description we want to use the
strip function to strip the white space
from the strings
so we're just getting the field name and
then stripping the value and putting
that back into what was initially there
for that value
okay now let's quickly look at
converting the product types uppercase
to lowercase if there is an uppercase
value for the for example thriller or
poetry values
we can specify specific keys that we're
looking for in this as I mentioned we'd
look at category you can also do things
like product type
and
we're going to
just
do the same thing except we're doing the
lower function on the value
now let's look at cleaning the price
data as I mentioned earlier and as part
of that make sure that the price data is
saved as a float
which can be important all the prices
aren't always going to be rounded up to
the nearest
dollar or pound or Euro for that kind of
data
so here
we Loop through the different price Keys
which because we're saving several
different pieces of data we've got price
price excluding tax price including tax
and the tax
and for each one of these we're
replacing the parent sign with nothing
and we can also
do something like replacing the for
example Unicode with a specific value
the other one I wanted to do was to
change the availability to remove the
extra text that was in there
so let me quickly add that in
to do that we're just doing the split
function on the bracket if it sees that
there's break there's no bracket there
then we'll just set the availability to
zero if there is a bracket there then we
will split the
second piece of the array that is
returned from this function
and we will say okay the second piece of
this
we'll split that again using the split
function and we then know that the
first item in this availability array is
going to be the availability number that
we had here
so this is going to be the first ISO in
that availability array and this is
going to be the second
so that should save just the number for
US of the availability and we'll save
that back into our item
let's just look at two other ones
quickly
so just converting the review to a
integer
so
we'll just convert Dash
so the number of reviews make sure that
it's an INT
so we're just going to adapter.get and
then we're using
our int and putting the string in inside
the brackets and saving that back into
the number of views variable and last of
all we mentioned the star rating and we
want to turn the star rating into an
integer also
so
to do that we can just get the Stars
split the string using the split
function again we've got the array we
take the second value in the array
converted to lowercase and then
depending on what the value is in that
variable is it zero one two three four
five then we save
the Stars value as 0 1 2 3 4 5. so
pretty easy
nothing too complicated there
so that's everything I wanted to cover
for for pipelines so as you can see
there's a huge amount of data processing
that you can do on pipelines and it's a
good idea to have a look at your data do
one run of it like we did in part five
and then have a look at your data and
actually see what you can fix what needs
to be fixed up what looks okay what
doesn't look okay
sometimes you'll get a missing piece of
data there'll be blanks but this is a
process of refinement so the first time
around you might only you know add in
two things to your item pipeline you run
it again and you notice something else
is wrong and you add in another piece
into this pipeline
so the next thing you want to do we talk
about this in part three is if you've
got a pipeline
you want to go into your settings and
you want to make sure that the pipeline
is enabled
so we've got our spider middlewares our
downloader middlewares extensions and as
you can see here
we've got our item Pipelines
so this book scraper pipeline
should correspond to the name of our
class here
and if I put that in you can see they're
the same so that should work because
this is also generated by scrape when
you generate the project
so it generally works as long as you
uncomment this section here
so
if everything was done correctly we
should be able to now run our spider and
see the results with all
the data processed just as we want it to
be processed here
if there's any errors they'll pop up and
we can fix them and run it again
so I'm just going to
make sure I'm in my project
and then
just you want scrape your list to make
sure everything's working and then
one Scrapy crawl book Spider
[Music]
hopefully there is no issues
okay straight away I can see there's an
error being returned so I'm just going
to
stop my spider
so none time none type object has no
attribute next call
and we can just
scroll up and double check this
so spider must return request item are
none because ice and meta in guess
okay so let's sort out this error
so if we just go back to our book
spider.py file
you can see the error is because I'm
returning
book item and yielding book item and
instead it should be book underscore
item
so that should fix the issue
and if I do a Scrapy crawl again
this time I'll actually get it to go
into another file we loot call clean
data dot Json
so it's the hyphen capital O clean
data.json and hopefully there's no other
errors
there it does look like there's another
error
because if I check clean data.json
there's nothing there okay so I'll just
close it again and you can see okay
error processing
availability
to give us anything else
so it says
pipelines.pyline 21. topple object has
no attribute strip
so we can go to our pipelines line 21
okay so we have our
value.strip
and it's saying Tuple object has no
attribute strip
so let's just
print out
the value
of value
let's just add in something above it so
we can just
see where it is in the output and try
runish one more time
and if we stop it again and scroll up we
should be able to see
that we've got our stars and we've got
in stock available at 19.
and it is indeed being returned in a
topple uh with the second
value
there's nothing there so obviously we
need to reference the first value in the
toggle so we need to just
do that
so
adding the square brackets since zero
should return
just the string that we're looking for
and then dot strip can act on this
string
so if we remove our print statements
save that and build Traverse again
and
it looks like there's some errors coming
in there we can just check our file
there's nothing in here yet
so I'll go ahead and stop the spider
from running
and
we can see an error here
pipelines.py line 21 in process item
so that's still giving it a bit this
line
but this time it's saying
type error none type object is not
subscriptable so
I know what this error is I've had it
before so this is coming up because
we're getting all the field names which
are a from our items.py so it's getting
all these different field names here
it's looping through them and one of
these field names is not
being found so if we look at our spider
and compare
all these guys here
versus
what we have here I think I've spotted
the one already so I think it's this
UPC field unique product code I think it
stands for
and if you look here we don't have book
item UPC
so I can just add that in now so I'll
add that in
here
and save that
so now we should have this
which should correspond to this and we
should have no more errors
so
let's run that again
and this time we should see our
clean data.json file filling up
so everything looks good there
open up the clean data chart Json we've
got
what looks like
all the data we wanted
so
we can go ahead and just
stop the spider don't need it to collect
all 1000 records you can just double
check that everything did go in
correctly so you can see just by either
checking the file or scrolling up
did everything get processed the way you
wanted to get processed so
did the price get get processed
correctly is it now double the product
type is the
first part lower case yes it is the
number of stars is now an integer
so it looks like everything that went
through our
pipelines.py got processed correctly
we can scroll up and check the category
as well and the availability so
everything worked out
so that's just how we go through using
pipelines and items
I hope that's given you a good idea of
how you can use items and pipelines
yourselves to clean the data that you're
scraping
and in part seven
which we'll be looking at next we'll be
looking at how we can use pipelines to
save our data into databases and also
how to use
feed exporters in a bit more detail so
see you in part seven guys
so for part 7 of our scrapey beginners
course we're going to look at all the
different ways we can save data so all
the data we've scraped in the last few
parts we're just going to see how can we
save it to different file formats and
then eventually look at databases
so first off we're going to look at Via
the command line how what commands we
need to run to save it to different file
formats then we're going to look at how
we can do that instead via the feed
settings which we can set in our
settings are in our main spider file and
then once we've done that we're going to
go on and look at saving data directly
into a database using the Pipelines
so if you've done part six with us you
know all about pipelines by now and
we'll be using those pipelines in part 7
to save the item and data into the
database directly
if you're just joining us now you can
download the code from our GitHub repo
we'll have links for that and you can
follow on from just this part 7. to get
going I'm just going to go into my
book scraper folder make sure I'm in the
right place
and then run Scrappy crawl and the name
of our spider
crawl book Spider Dash capital O
and then
book
data.cs V
so this is going to Output the data into
a CSV format which is comma separated
values so that can be opened in Excel
and as you can see the data is all there
correctly okay so we can stop that now
and if we scroll to the bottom we can
see we have
321 rows
so
if you want to append data onto a file
instead of The Hyphen or Dash capital O
you can do a lowercase o
and then if we do the same name again
book data.csv
and enter
it should start pending on the data here
so instead of overwriting the file every
time
if we close the file
open it back up you can see we're
already up to over 500 records so the
file doesn't update automatically
sometimes it can take a couple of
seconds or you have to close it and
reopen it
so as you can see we're up to 700
records there and if I relish once more
and do a capital O
it will overwrite that
there you go so it's after wiping the
file and now filling it again
okay
so that's the difference with the
overwriting are appending and you've
seen just by changing the file format at
the end of your file name
is how you can specify types of
files that you want to write into so
here we're going to do it again but
we're going to do it in Json file format
so we have a new file is created book
data.json
as you can see it's in Json format
and the other one
is comma separated values format
now let's move on and look at how we can
specify where the data will be saved in
our settings file
so if we open up our settings file
what we can do is use the feeds so what
we do is
add in a feed section
and here we're saying save the data into
a file called data.json
so that's the scholars
books data
dot Json and the format is going to be
Json so if I delete the two files we've
just been using there
and save what I have in my settings
and rerun it except this time
remove the
Dash o and the name of the file and if I
just go ahead and run my spider
we've seen it's just created at books
data.json because I've specified it here
and it's all in the correct format
so I'm just going to go ahead and stop
my spider and the next thing you want to
do is just show you guys how you can
specify the feed
data in your spider so to do that we can
use the custom settings
so this just enables you to overwrite
anything you have in your
settings file
and you can just specify it in your
spider so just need to specify what we
want to overwrite
and we're going to overwrite our feed
and we would then push
our feed
settings in here
so if it sees that the feeds are set
here it will overwrite what we have in
our settings.py file
so this is just an easy way that if you
guys want to specify certain settings
you can do them here they don't all have
to be in your settings.py file
one important thing to note as well with
our feeds when we either set it in
settings or in custom settings is we
need to set the overwriting so like we
did earlier
we just have overrice true our overwrite
false because it depends on where you're
storing the data what the default is for
that setting so it's better just to
specify that we want to or write the
file or not we can just have it there
and run it and it'll overwrite our
current file
so now that we have that the next thing
we want to look at is how to save our
data into databases using our Pipelines
so I've gone ahead and I've already
installed MySQL so MySQL is a very
popular
database which you can get yourselves
just by going to
mysql.com site and their download
section and you can just choose your
operating system so if you've got
windows
obviously have it for Windows click
download and install it then they have
for many other operating systems the
available downloads there too
so once you've downloaded and installed
that you should be able to then make
sure it's installed correctly just by
running MySQL and then dash dash version
so as you can see here I have version
8.0.32 for Mac OS 11. and that's the
latest 8.0.32
so that's installed for me so the next
thing I'm going to do is just Connect
into my MySQL
so I can just type MySQL and then if
it's a simple install and you've just
installed this you should be able to
just hit enter and it brings you
straight in
and you know you're connected in because
you've got MySQL here and then you can
just say
show databases
and it shows the databases so I've
already gone ahead and created one
called books
that's there but you obviously won't
have that if you just installed it so
you want to create a database so you
just do create
database
books and then it'll say
created I've already got the database
already there so it says database exists
for me
so we need a database to actually Savor
things into and once it's set up it'll
be there in your list and you just do
show
databases
to get the list of databases that are
available
so we can exit out of that once we have
our database created
you might have to connect in to your
MySQL if you've set up a username and
password are with a different host if
you've so you could do host
localhost
minus U for user root and minus P if
you've got a password and then it'll
prompt you for a password
so depending on what you have
so that also works to connect in
if I'd set up a password it would have
asked me for a password beforehand so if
you just type MySQL you can usually get
in if you ever already haven't got a
password set up or if you're using a
different host like digitalocean or some
other third-party provider you can stick
the URL to where your database is hosted
there
so we've got our database set up and the
next thing we want to do is we want to
install
our MySQL connector so just to make sure
that python is able to connect to our
database
so I'm just going to paste in the
command for that and you guys can
have a look at my screen there and type
it in so it's going to install the MySQL
and MySQL connector python packages
with using pip again so
go ahead and run that
and now that I have that I should be
able to start working on the pipeline
so we can just go directly under our
existing book scraper pipeline
and we're going to create
a new class
and we're just going to call that save
to mySQL pipeline
and then we're going to import our MySQL
connector to help us connect in
and we're going to initially just
when this pipeline is initialized we're
going to
set up our connection
and then set up our cursor
so I'll show you guys now what that
entails
so we have this init function here so
this is going to start up when
our spider
initializes this class
we have we're using the MySQL
connector.connect here to set up the
connection we've got our host our
username password if you have a password
you have to add it in here and then the
database that we just created books
so we can save all that and then we have
the cursor which is used to execute the
commands
so I have that set up here and that's
saved into self dot Cur so we can use it
further in other functions
so the next thing we want to do is we're
going to add in
that we want a new table to be created
if there is no table to store the data
so this can just be handy in case you
are running this over and over again
or you're testing you might want to go
in drop the table and if you don't want
to remember did I just create that is a
table there or not you would have this
there so that will just make sure that
there's a table there so it creates a
table if it doesn't exist called books
and that table will have the following
columns ID URL title UPC product type
everything that we've already been
scraping from the page all the different
data points
so it will set up all these different
columns including a primary key called
ID and then all the data will be able to
saved into the columns that we want it
to be saved into
so we'll have the table set up if it's
not already set up so that's we don't
have to go in and manually set it up in
MySQL ourselves
and the next thing we'd want to look at
is
we're going to again use the process
item function
so we've already had that in our other
pipeline but we're going to add it in
here
and this is where we're going to have
our insert statement so it's going to
insert our data that we have in our item
so here it is
pretty simple so using the cursor that
we've already defined above I'm going to
say please execute this command insert
into books URL title UPC product type
all the pieces of data that we've
already scraped
so
once that's insert statement just there
we have to use commit to make sure that
the insert is actually executed
correctly and then we just return the
item
so that if we add one more layer to our
pipeline that the item is returned and
the next piece of our pipeline can also
continue the only other thing we need to
add in now is
we want the connection to our database
to be closed once the spider is finished
so to do that we just add in that
enclosed spider so this is just
a function that's scrapey looks for if
close spider is there it executes closed
spider once the spider is ready to close
at the end
so inside enclosed spider we just add in
cursor close and connection close so
we're just closing the cursor and the
connection
just so that this stuff isn't kept open
and using memory if we're executing this
lots and lots of times we don't want all
this memory to be taken up with cursors
and connections that are not being used
so now that we have that we need to go
to our settings and we need to enable
our new pipeline
so we're just going to copy the existing
line and we're going to say
execute our pipeline after this
and existing one so we want the data to
be clean first and the second step is
save the data into our mySQL database so
we're going to just copy the class name
go to settings
paste that in here
and then the only thing we need to do is
we need to change this number here
so I don't think I've talked about this
number yet
so what this number is is that it's just
the order in which the items in the item
pipeline have precedence so the lower
the number the higher
the order of importance the first thing
that's going to be executed so in this
case number 300 is going to be executed
first and then number 400 is going to be
executed after that so this is an easy
way for us to say please execute this
pipeline first and this pipeline second
and if you had multiple pipelines you
can just use these numbers it doesn't
have to be three or four hundred it can
be any number you want I've just picked
three and four hundred for now
okay so now that we have that we should
be able to go ahead and check our
database to see did the
items get saved into the database
correctly
so let's do that now
so as before we're just going to do
Scrappy crawl book Spider
and
should kick off
so we have several books after being
scraped so that's let's stop our spider
the next thing we want to do is we want
to
log back into our
MySQL console
and then we want to
show database
this is
and then we want to use
books
this just enables us to select from that
database
so once we're using the books database
we want to just
show tables
and we can see that the table was
created that we asked to create books
and then we can do
select all
from books
and we can see that there's 138 rows
there and Dash D data looks like it's
safe correctly we've got the name of the
books
all the other pieces of data that we had
the description the price
the tax
the availability the category it all
looks like it's saved there correctly
so we can
drop the table
so dropping the table just basically
removes the table so that it won't exist
drop table books
if we want to start again because
otherwise what it's going to do is it's
going to keep appending on to the
database
so we can see if we show tables that
there's no more tables in the database
now
but our pipeline creates a new table
anyway so that's fine
so that's how we create a simple
database
get it set up and have a simple pipeline
script that
once the data is cleaned up with our
first pipeline that we did in part six
it then inserts it into a mySQL database
in this tutorial that we've just done
again using our Pipelines so obviously
if you're
more familiar with using postgres
databases or other types of databases
you can just modify the pipeline
slightly we will have available articles
where it'll show you the exact code you
need to use a pipeline to insert the
database into a postgres database also
so you guys can have a look at the
articles that we'll attach and we'll
also have the code repos there for you
guys to
just download and play around with two
so I think that's it for part seven in
part eight we're going to be looking at
how we can use
the user agents and headers to get
around issues with being blocked when
we're trying to scrape different
websites
so we're going to be looking at user
agents and headers in detail what they
are how to use them
so see you in partake guys thanks for
watching
welcome to part 8 of the scrapey
beginners course
for a free code camp
so in part 8 we're going to be looking
at why we get blocked when we're
scraping the web
what types of websites might block us
and then how to use user agents and
headers to bypass instances where we're
getting blocked while scraping
so we'll start off by going straight
into what headers are
so if you go to the site we've been
scraping in the last two parts
books.2scrape.com
you open inspect
an element on the page go to the
networking Tab and then
simply refresh the page if you've got
doc selected or all selected you will
see what we want to see
so because this is a just a simple
website the HTML is sent to us and we
can see it returned in the preview
so you can see all the HTML is there
and that's what we end up scraping when
we are using scrapey
but if we look at the headers tab
we can see everything that is sent when
we request this page and you've got the
request URL which is just the URL of the
site we're trying to scrape you've got
the method are we trying to get the page
are we posting data to the page
and then you've got things like the
status code
and so on so on now the important stuff
for us are the request headers
so this is everything that we send when
we make a request to books.2script.com
and as part of this
the most important part for us in this
part eight
of the tutorial is the user agent
so the user agent
gives you all the important information
about who you are to the server that
you're requesting the web page from so
here we can see if I copy this string
and I've got this site user agent
string.com and it lets you paste in
and analyze user agents
so this is all the stuff that
is is contained when we make a request
to a website
straight away it knows that we're using
Chrome what version of Chrome we're
using
the render engine
that we're using
your operating system so I'm using OS X
I'm using an Intel CPU so all this kind
of data is sent with every request you
make automatically
now this is fine when you're browsing
the web or you're building your spiders
and you're doing a bit of testing but if
you're doing any sort of large-scale
scraping on any kind of commercial sites
you're more than likely going to start
to get blocked
so a lot of sites think I don't know
Amazon Walmart
any kind of big eCommerce sites most of
them will have some form of antibots
that stop you from scraping now you
might say why do they want to stop me
I'm not doing anything bad I just want
to collect their data well they'll say
well this is our data we own the website
this is only for our customers
so on so forth now obviously
you need to look at the terms conditions
of the site you're scraping and judge
for yourself if it's legal or illegal
the rule of thumb to go by is that if
it's publicly available and you don't
have to log in and give your details
then it's more than likely okay to
scrape the data of the website if you
have to log in first and by logging in
you might be agreeing to certain terms
and conditions then more than likely the
website will have that in their terms
and conditions that you are not allowed
to scrape their data so that's up to you
guys to decide in a case-by-case basis
but for a lot of simpler sites like the
one where
we're scraping in our tutorial series
here
this site has no antibots on it so there
is nothing which will block us even if
we have the same user agent
so therefore it knows if if it gets a
thousand requests
from this chrome and my Mac that it
knows that it's me then it's it's not
going to do anything about it it's not
going to block me when I'm trying to
scrape all these books off this website
but that's obviously because this
website is there for people to learn on
so
that's kind of why we get blocked so the
other things that they look for is they
look at the IP address of the machine
that you're using so that's also a a
very simple way for websites to block
who the requests because they can see
your IP address every time you make a
request so they normally look for the IP
address
and they might set something in your
cookies in your session so they might
set some kind of flag or counter there
so they know that it's you coming back
every time
so it's mainly IP address the cookies or
the sessions and then the headers in
general and as part of that the user
agents so the difference between headers
and user agents is that headers
is everything that we have here
so it it encompasses things like the
accepted things that are returned does
it take HTML or does it take images you
know what do we accept back what does
the browser accept back as a as a
response to things like the language
encoding and then the user agent is just
one
subset of the overall request headers
so
for some sites that are not too complex
if we change the user agent each time we
make a request
the website will think that it is a
different browser and a different
computer looking for the data on the
site every time so it'll let the request
go through however for more complicated
sites they'll look at everything in the
request headers and they'll want
everything to be different or at least
slightly different so
for example I have Mac OS here so if Mac
OS is coming every single time and they
match that plus they can see my Google
Chrome version here as well and the
version of chromium then they might say
okay this looks too similar even though
their user agent is changing every time
this looks suspicious and they might
flag my requests and block my requests
or at least they might not even block
them but they might throw up a capture
page so that if you're not actively
solving the capture
the requests are being blocked
so for the most comp for the more
complicated sites we need to also be
changing the entirety of the request
headers not just the user agents
so they're the kind of main things we
need to look at is how can we change
your IP address to stop getting blocked
how can we change our user agents and
also the entirety of the request headers
for the more complicated sites so that's
what we're going to be doing in part 8
and part nine is looking how to bypass
being blocked by changing these
different parts that are sent when we
make a request for a web page
okay
so now that we've gone through the
theory of it of what is in a header and
user agent and what details the websites
are looking at when we make a request
let's go to our spider and Implement
different user agents every time
how we can get multiple different user
agents insert them into our spider use
middlewares to do that and then also do
it for request headers
okay so if we go back to our spider
we're continuing on from part seven if
you're just joining us for this part
eight we have a link to download the
code so you can hop in and start right
here with us now
so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to
just go to my settings and disable
the pipeline which saves the data to
mySQL because I don't need to do that
for the purpose of this part H so the
next thing is I'm going to open up my
spider
and
I'm going to set a user agent so I'm
going to do that the simplest way to do
it is actually to go to our settings
and in the settings we can directly set
a user agent
so
just like I had shown you in the browser
it's user agent and then it contains all
the available information about
the user who is requesting the web data
so here you can see Mac OS X
you can see it's an iPad
etc etc etc so this is just an example
if you wanted to send this user agent
with every single request you can set it
in the settings now obviously that
doesn't make sense because
it's not changing So within 10 or 20
requests the website is going to say hey
this is the same person every time
they're making a lot of requests they're
probably web scraping and they'll ask
for capture audio blockers so this is
not sufficient this is just if you want
to set one specific user agent for every
single request so for now we'll remove
that again
and we will look at how we can create a
list and rotate through that list
so what we're going to do is go back to
our spider and we are going to create a
list of user agents
so here's one I've pasted in from our
article you can check out our article
and paste it in yourself as well
and we also have this available in the
GitHub repo so you don't have to type
out everything here yourself
so we've got a list the next thing we
want to do is
add the user agent into every single
request that we make
so to do that
we can go to where we make the requests
every time
and we can specify that we want our user
agent to be overwritten to do that we
just
go to where we have our callback and our
book URL
and we would do something like this
so we would have our headers and we're
saying
overwrite the user agent part of our
headers
and we'll do this with our user agent
list
so we just need to specify self dot user
agent list
and then
we'll import random so we can
switch between different things at
random and we'll do self.user agent list
here and I think that's all we need
so what this does is we're saying
add this user agent to our headers when
we make the request and pick
a random user agent from between 0 and
the length of the user agent so it's
going to pick
one of these guys at random and insert
it in to our header
now obviously you need to add this
line that we just added to everywhere
that is
making a response dot follow
so we can add it here as well
and I think that's the only two places
we have them
so
we should be able to run that
and it should send a different user
agent every time
but as you might guess
this isn't really enough to spoof a
large-scale website they'll see if
you're doing thousands of requests okay
there's only
five different user agents and they'll
say we need to block this user
so that brings us on to how we can use a
fake user agent API to give us a massive
list of thousands of user agents and
then we can Loop through that list of
thousands of user agents but instead of
having them all here directly in our
spider what we would do is we would
Implement and middleware
and we would add it into our
middlewares.py and in this middleware is
where we would rotate through all the
different fake user agents that we would
be getting from a fake user agent API
so that's what we're going to look at
next we're going to create a middleware
and we're going to ask for those fake
user Agents from the third-party website
get those user agents returned to us
again pass those in to our request
headers
so to get those request headers we can
go back to our browser and go to
scrapeups.io
where you can sign up for a free account
and then using the API key that you get
you can use the free headers generator
API
so this is what happens when I use their
headers API I can specify that I want
user agents I put in my API key
there make a request and it gives me
back a result with a bunch of different
randomly generated user agents so once
you're actually logged in
you can go to their
fake headers API section and that's
where it shows you your API key and if
you want to generate browser headers
you use this URL if you want to generate
user agents
you use that URL and then the response
comes back like this just as I showed
you here
so I can just
stick that in and it gives me the
results back so you can specify the
number of headers you want and it sends
you back all the user agents our browser
headers that we can then use in our
middleware
so depending on the language you're
using as well you can specify different
examples so
this is where I got the URL to use
for here
and if you're using node or PHP a ruby
you could use the other tabs to see the
examples but we're using python with
scraping so we have everything we need
here
so now that we have an API endpoint
where we can get our fake user agents
and fake headers
we can go back to our middlewares file
and we can start creating our middleware
that will handle everything to do with
the fake user agents so I'm just going
to scroll down to the bottom and I'm
going to start
a new class
and I'm going to be importing a couple
of things that we're going to need
so I'm going to import your link code
which will encode our urls
ran into pick a random integer so we can
use that to pick one from the list and
requests as well
so I've created a new class called
scrape UPS fake user agent middleware
that can be obviously whatever you want
it to be
and then we're going to set it up
so again we have our initial
function which gets kicked off when the
class is initialized
and in here we first off set some of our
settings
so we're going to want the scrape UPS
API key which is going to be the API key
that we get for free from
here so that's where we have our API key
we also have the URL
which you can see
here
and
so we've got our endpoint
and what else oh yeah do we want it to
be enabled or not and the number of
results we want to specify to come back
so
we go ahead and set those all up in our
settings
so I'm going to set my
API key
obviously you guys set that to whatever
your one is
set up the endpoint
and the end point is going to be user
agents
paste static
and then we have our
if we have enabled
so that's true
there you go
and
the num requests
which we can set to to 50.
you can save that and
save that as well so this part up here
just makes sure that we have access to
our crawler settings when d-class is
initialized
so as you can see here and here we've
got two functions
and that means when the class is
initialized get the user agents list and
enable it
so I'm going to first off get the user
agents list so I'm gonna add that one in
so that function looks like
following
we've got the payload set which is the
API key
and then we're saying if the number of
results is not none set the payload
number results
and then we want to make a get request
to the API endpoint with our
parameters which have been URL encoded
here using the URL encode function then
that goes off goes to the script ops
endpoint and then gets the user agents
and comes what comes back gets put into
the response
then we're using dot Json just to parse
it into a Json response
and then we can
have our user agents list saved into
user agents list
so once we've got that we're going to
just
create two more simple functions
underneath
the first one just get random user agent
fairly self-explanatory
let's get one and getting one user agent
from the list that's been returned and
returned that selected user agent
and then we have
just this check to see if the fake user
agents is either active or inactive
and then once all that's set we can
actually
put that into practice with our process
requests which is one of the scrapey
functions that's it's one of the
functions that scrapey will look for
when you're using middlewares
and
it then sees that we've specified
something to happen when it goes to
processor request and then it executes
the following
so when it sees process request it goes
in here it gets a random user agent
sticks it in here and then it sets the
header user agent to be the random user
agent so I hope that makes sense I think
it's fairly self-explanatory we're just
getting a list of user agents
and then with process request we are
getting a random user agent and we are
assigning that to our header request
header so when we go off and ask our
books to scrape site
for the book or the list of books it
sticks in dash random user agent
into the user agent of the request
the only thing to do then is to stick
our middleware this is a step you
mustn't forget it's very easy to forget
it I've forgotten it loads of times and
then sometimes you can be trying to
debug things after
so you want to go to your downloader
middlewares
open that
and add in your new middleware
so again as we did in the last one the
lower number has higher priority
so we don't need to have
the other downloader middleware just
want our
a middleware we just created our scrape
Ops fake user agent middleware
because this middleware up here is just
the generated one that we don't need at
the moment
okay we'll go ahead run our spider now
check that it's working
should be working fine
and then we will look at
just doing the same thing but instead of
having
a user agent come back from scrape-ups
We'll be asking for a list of fake
headers so we'll create a second
middleware
and we'll just have the whole fake
header as opposed to just the subsection
user agent part
so just to make sure that the headers
are being attached correctly because you
might say oh I know for sure that it's
working we can just add in a very simple
print to our process request
so
I'm just going to stick this in here two
print statements one sync new header
attached and the other one saying the
new user agent so it'll print out the
user agent that we've just attached the
random user agent so that should print
that out then to our console and we
should be able to see that a new user
agent is being attached every time that
request is being processed you out the
only other thing we have to do is go
back and remove what we added in earlier
which was this header's part here
because it's being done in middleware so
we don't have to specify it for every
request here so I'm just going to remove
that
and I'm going to remove it here as well
so as you can see there's always
multiple ways of doing it either kind of
manually adding things into the spider
setting them in the settings if you just
want it once off in the settings if you
want a simple case The Spider and if you
want something more complex in the
middleware so you've kind of got your
three different ways of adding
your user agents are headers in
so now that we've removed that we don't
need this user agents list up here
we can remove that let's save it
and
we should be able to just run our spider
again so
Scrappy crawl
and
book Spider
and if everything's gone to plan we
should see I'll just close the spider
straight away
and scroll up so we can have a look and
see to everything so it looks like all
the data is coming back as it was before
we don't expect anything to change there
because we we're not going to be getting
blocked by the books to scrape.com site
anyway but if we scroll up I think we
should see
here you go so here is where we can see
the all the new headers that are coming
in
so
you can see the Chrome version there is
different
sometimes it looks like it's using Edge
as well
so you can see there's multiple
different headers coming back
and then they are being attached in with
the process request
so that all seems to be working fine
just as we wanted to and we made sure
that we had it enabled in the settings
as well
in the downloader middlewares so we have
an enabled there
as well as enabled up here and the
number of
user agents coming back from the API set
here
so everything is
as it should be one other thing to note
is that this robot's txt underscore a
bay is set to true if we're starting to
do more complex sites we would set this
to false
so every site or most sites have a
robots.txt file
which is usually one of the first things
that a spider will look for so scrapey
does this automatically every time it
looks at a site it first goes off and
checks does the site have a robot dot
txt file and in that robots.txt file is
usually specified things like the pages
on the site is this site open to being
scraped and if it's open to being
scraped watch pages are not allowed to
be scraped are what pages are allowed to
be scraped now obviously any crawlers
that go out crawl different websites
don't have to obey this robots.txt file
you know it's it's a piece of code it's
going to go off and do what you tell us
this is up to you to decide you know do
you want your spider to obey it or not a
lot of big sites will have like okay if
you're a Google spider you're allowed
crawl and scrape our data if you're not
a Google spider don't scrape our data so
if they have that in their robots.txt
and you have it set to obey is equal to
True your spider will go see it's not
supposed to scrape the site and it'll
shut down so if you're having issues and
you have this set to True try setting it
to false
okay so now that we've gone through what
robots.txt entails let's go and create
our next middleware
so this time instead of
having middleware that just replaces the
user agent every time we're going to
create a new middleware so go to
middlewares.py
and this new middleware is going to
create a new header every time using the
data that it gets back from the fake
browser header endpoint
so I'm just going to paste in the code
here and then talk through it for you
guys
so
if we go up to the top we start off
again with just a simple class name
scrape UPS fake browser header agent
middleware that can be whatever you want
we pull in the settings that we need
this will get everything from the
settings file
and then it kicks off get headers list
which calls out to the API endpoint
it does a get request here
to the scrape UPS endpoint
Returns the response converts it to Json
and then we've got a list of headers
and then in the process request which
gets processed with every request
we have this get random browser header
function which will get the random
browser header from the list that we
just asked for from scrape UPS so then
we have this random browser header and
we can assign
all the other headers not just user
agent like we did in the middleware
above but we can also modify all these
other parameters in the header
so you don't have to modify all of them
you can modify certain ones again this
is up to you to play around with and
decide which ones you need which ones
you don't need
with scraping everything is really a
case-by-case basis because every website
is different
but we're giving you here everything you
need to play around with
so you might find certain headers need
to be modified more than others we have
our request.headers
being updated
and then that is just like the one above
everything we need
let's go ahead now and add the settings
that we need
so we have some of the settings already
set here so we have the browser endpoint
there's a default set there we can set
our fake browser header enabled to True
here to make sure it runs and then the
num requests is going to be the same as
here it's already set and the API key is
already set as well so again you get
your own API key for that
and I think we should be able to just go
to settings now and make sure we have
the middleware enabled so I'm copying
the class name
going to settings going down to
downloader middlewares and where we had
the fake user agent middleware I'm just
going to overwrite that so we have our
fake browser header agent middleware
so I'm going to save that and then just
go and run the spider again
and it should work correctly
so yeah there seems to be
lots of books getting scraped
so it seems to be working correctly I
can stop it and just as we did before
to double check that the
headers are being
set correctly
we can just stick underneath
a simple print statement
that shows the headers are set
to what we wanted them to be set to
so
if we run our spider it should show that
there's multiple different headers
so I'm stopping it again and looking at
the output
once we get past the book data
okay so here there's some headers so new
header attached which is what we have
here and then
we can see we have things like let's see
accept
the user agent so okay so we have
the user agent Mozilla 5
do we have accept
so we have accept the text HTML
everything we wanted there
I'm just trying to see can we see in
here that both of them are different to
each other
yeah so here for example you can see
this user agent is using Chrome 103.0
50 60.134
and up here it's using a different
version of Chrome
so it's using one zero three point zero
point fifty sixty one one four
so you can see it is
changing in each request
so that's exactly what we want to show
you how to do
so I think that concludes part eight
in part nine we'll be going into how to
use proxies
to bypass the anti-bot blockers that
websites have as well so instead of kind
of handling everything ourselves and
trying to bypass the antibots by
updating our own headers we can see that
there's commercial things out there for
you to do that with and there's also
things like proxy lists that are free to
use as well and we look at how to
integrate those into your scrapey
project as well
so see you in part nine guys
so in part nine of the scrapey beginners
course we're going to be looking at
everything to do with proxies so we're
going to be going through what are
proxies and why do we need them and then
we're going to be looking at the three
most popular ways to integrate proxies
into your projects
so let's get started
so in part 8 we're looking at user
agents and requests and the headers we
pass in when we're making the requests
to the website you're looking to scrape
we discussed and looked at how if you
change your headers and change your user
agents you can basically make it look as
if you were multiple people accessing
the website you're trying to scrape
now there's one thing we also mentioned
in part eight which is that the data
that also is being transmitted with your
request is usually your IP address
so this IP address is it's your unique
identifier
and that's what is used to make sure the
data comes back to your machine
so every machine will have an IP address
and that's how the requests get to and
from your machine think of it as like
your house as an address your computer
must also need an address and this is
your IP address so if we change the user
agents every time when we're sending the
requests that's fine but if we changing
the user agents every time but we still
have the same IP address then the site
that we're scraping is very likely to
know that we are the same machine that
is requesting their data every time so
they're very likely to block us straight
away
so that's why changing our IP address as
well as our user agent and headers is
very important so just the user agent
and headers might work if it's not very
sophisticated type of website that
you're trying to scrape but if you're
going to anything that's complex at all
you will need to rotate your IP address
and that's where proxies come into play
so
let's first off look at the first method
is that we're going to be looking at is
using proxy lists so these are lists of
IP addresses and ports that belong to
multiple different servers all over the
world so there's lots of these machines
that are available to bypass our
requests will go via that machine before
it goes to the website we're trying to
scrape and then it'll come all the way
back via that machine as well now
there's pros and cons to every one of
the of the three integration methods
we're going to look at so the pros of
proxy lists like this are that obviously
the proxies that list that you can get
online are last number free so like this
one here
freeproxylist.net you can go there and
you can select from a list of different
countries select your protocols and you
can check the uptime there's also
another list which is very handy on
juno.com forward slash free proxy list
here you also have IP address Port
country uptime response Etc
so here there is 9 000 proxies online in
136 countries but the downside is of
using these lists is that because
they're free so many people are using
them that they're very likely to either
have very poor response times and take
very long time to actually root your
traffic through them or else they can be
already blacklisted because think of it
if someone has already used them to
scrape millions of pages from maybe the
same site that you're going to look to
scrape data from then there's a very
high likelihood that that website could
already have discovered this IP address
and blocked it
so the pro is that it's free the cons
are that it can take a long time and
there's a very high likelihood that if
it's free that it's already been used
too much and it could be blocked
so we're going to go ahead anyway and
try with a few of these IP addresses and
a few ports from these two sites and the
way we want to integrate them into our
project is we're going to use this
GitHub project which integrates with
scrapey and it's called scrippy rotating
proxies
so we'll have a link to this
available but you can just do pip
install scrapey Dash rotating Dash
proxies
and go to your terminal
and
paste that in and run it
now I already have it installed so it's
going to say requirement already
satisfied for me but for you guys you
should see it installed in there
now we're continuing on part nine from
part eight so if you're looking for the
code for where we are starting at now
we'll have that available in a GitHub
repo which we link to
so you can continue on from here with us
so now that we have that installed we
can go ahead and
we can add our proxy list in so as you
probably guess everything is going to go
into our settings file
as with everything else that's part of
our project
and these are just dummy
domain IP addresses
but this is the idea so you can have
this many you could have a hundred
different IP address and ports in here
but we're just going to put three or
four
just for the purpose of showing you how
it works
so let's go back to our free proxy list
and take
two of these guys
so we want the IP address in the port
now obviously depending on your use case
you might need
a
and you might need a proxy from a
specific country
or you might need
a proxy with a very good uptime or
response time
so that's for you guys to search in the
search boxes on the site here
okay so I've got three of them there
and the next thing I want to do is
enable the middleware so this project
that I've just installed this scrapey
rotating proxies will have installed a
middleware
but to actually make sure that the
middleware works we need to add it to
our downloader middlewares
and that's where we can
make sure it's enabled
so I've just done gone ahead and done
that there I've added them in so
and as you can see I've left the other
two middlewares that we had from part 8
in here as well so obviously they don't
have to be here I can also remove them
but I might as well leave them in for
now they're not going to do any harm
they're just adding in
a different request header
so let's save that
and then the other thing I wanted to
quickly show you is that if you had all
the proxies already in a file you could
do something as simple as
just saying the rotating proxy list path
is equal to and then the path to your
file obviously we don't have a file with
a bunch of ips and ports but that's
where you would put it if that's what
you're wanting to do
so let's just quickly remove that
and now we can go ahead and we can run
our spider and see the results so I'm
just going to do scrippy crawl and the
name of the spider
I'm just going to make sure and in my
project
it's great big crawl
the book Spider
so it's going to go ahead and run you
can see
the header that was attached from part 8
where we were adding the new header
and now this can take a good bit of time
so as you can see here this rotating
proxies Dot middlewares
has printed out that
it has zero good proxies
zero dead proxies and three unchecked
proxies
so that means that it's going to go
ahead and it's first going to try and
see can it actually send any requests
through the proxies that we've listed
here so this can take a good bit of time
depending on the quality of the proxies
that we've got obviously I have no idea
how good the ones in that free list are
because they change every day every hour
there's new ones added and there's ones
removed and then as soon as they're
added they're being used by hundreds if
not thousands of other users
so
this is the good thing about this
middleware is that it checks cannot
actually use it and as you can see here
it's just retrying our books to scrape
URL with another proxy because one of
them failed to work
so it's just a process of waiting so
it's moved one of the proxies into our
dead pool and it's still got two that it
wants to check
so this is just a process of waiting and
letting the middleware do its work so
I'm gonna leave that run for a few
minutes and come back to it and we'll
see did it actually manage to use any of
those
free proxies that were on that free
proxy list
so I'll come back in one second and
we'll see where we are okay so I've just
come back a few minutes later and
it still hasn't managed to
get any of our three proxies in the list
to work
he's got two dead now one it's trying to
reanimate
it's not looking good so obviously the
ones I've picked were probably already
overly used already could be blocked by
the site we're trying to scrape
so here you can see obviously the major
disadvantage of using free proxy lists
online now there's lots of different
places to get them so depending on your
source of the proxies you may have much
better luck at getting them to work but
it's really a process of trial and error
and while it's free it can be painful to
actually get up and running consistently
and correctly
so
we've had a look at how we can just
plug in a bunch of different IP
addresses and ports into our rotating
proxy list and how we can use this
middleware to use our proxies in our
scrapey project but another way we can
do this is
using a proxy port so what we would be
using is a service which is provided by
a proxy provider
and they would give us a proxy IP
address and port and they would handle
changing the IP address every time and
we wouldn't have to worry about
compiling a list of proxies ourselves so
that's what we're going to look at next
so we can still be looking after our own
user agents and our own headers but the
proxy provider would be dealing with
everything to do with rotating a proxy
list for us and making sure that the
proxy list is of good quality and
available all the time so we wouldn't
have to worry about that now there's
lots of them out there and we're just
going to look at one of them now
the one I've just going to show you now
is called smart proxy you can check them
out at smartproxy.com
and as they say effortlessly scrape web
data you need so they've got some great
deals and offers and as you can see they
you know do things like bypassing
captures IP bands they've got millions
of proxies from millions of locations
and the plans they do entail residential
and data center proxies so we haven't
talked about that yet but residential
proxies would be basically the data will
be forwarded through residential IP
addresses so these are IP addresses that
are mainly used by people's homes so
think of it if someone is watching
Netflix and browsing Facebook and
looking at Google search and then
one or two of your requests are going
via that IP address then the website
you're trying to scrape let's say Amazon
is going to say oh well I saw that IP
address yesterday they just bought
something from me so they're much more
likely just to let that request go
through without any issue so that would
be what residential proxies are then
data center proxies would be think of
you know your traditional data centers
with thousands of servers in a big room
and your requests will be routed through
a Data Center and through the IP address
that is belonging to one of the machines
in the data center
so you have access to a lot more IP
addresses in the residential side but
then the data center side are much
quicker and there tends to be not as
many data limits and they tend to be a
bit cheaper as well so that's the
difference between residential and data
center proxies so you can sign up with
them most proxy providers also give you
a week or two of a free trial or a
certain amount of free credits that you
can use to test out their service so if
you guys go ahead you can click get
started there sign up for an account and
then once you're logged in
if you go to the residential tab
because we're going to be using
residential proxies for our next part
now so click the residential Tab and
then you can either check out a pay as
you go plan where you pay per gigabytes
of data that's transferred or you can go
into regular or Enterprise as well so I
already have a plan set up with them so
I'm going to go directly to the proxy
setup next
and this is where we will get our
details which we'll then put into our
spider first off we want to generate our
username and password so we can put in
any kind of combination of
letters and numbers here a password
and click create and it creates a
username and password once you have your
username and password you can grab these
and put those into the username and
password field here then our proxy
location if it's important for your
spider that you are scraping from a
certain country for example if you're
scraping an e-commerce site that will
only show you specific products if
you're living in a certain country then
it is important to select the country
here from this list so for us it doesn't
matter so we can leave it at random
then for the session type we want
rotating because we don't want a fixed
session every request can come from a
different IP address and that doesn't
matter for us right now and for the
output format we're just going to pick
http
so that's going to then give us this
string here which we can copy and use in
our project so this is the endpoint
where we're going to send our requests
to Smart proxy is going to handle all
the IP address rotation and all that
stuff and it's going to then send us
back the response from the website we
are trying to scrape
now that we have our endpoint
from Smart proxy the next thing we want
to do is go back to our project
we want to disable the middleware we
were using because that will no longer
be needed because
smart proxy is going to be looking after
rotating our proxies and it's going to
be looking after some band detection
stuff as well
so we can disable the two of them
and the next thing we can do is go to
our spider
and we can go to where we have
response.follow and in here we'll simply
add in
one more field which
is going to be meta and then the proxy
information so matter is equal to
proxy and then our proxy details will go
in here
so I can go back
grab my proxy endpoint and paste it in
here
so
that looks correct
and then I can also copy this
and put it down where we also have
response dot follow
below
so I'll add it in here too
and
that should be the two main places I
needed for now
the other example which I'll show you in
a second is that we can create a custom
middleware which would insert the
endpoint and as well so we'll do that
once we get this to run correctly
we can now do Scrapy crawl book spider
and it should work for us so Scrapy
crawl book Spider
and hopefully we have no issues
as I can see there's some things coming
through
I can go to my books data.json
and I can see that there is
the data coming through so it looks like
it's working correctly and it's all
going via
the
smart proxy endpoint so I can
close down my spider and the next thing
we can do is we can create a custom
middleware version so just adding it in
to our
meta
value here and adding in our proxy
endpoint is fine if you've got a small
project
but if you've got a larger project it
probably makes more sense just to make a
custom middleware for it so I'm going to
show you how to do that next
so we'll scroll down to the bottom
because we have our other middle words
in here already
and we'll create a new middleware
where we will be adding our endpoint
details
so
we just make a new class called my proxy
middleware
it's going to again pull in our crawler
settings and then it's going to get our
proxy user proxy password proxy endpoint
and proxy port from our settings so we
need to go ahead and set those in our
settings
and then once it's got those it makes
the user credentials it puts those
credentials into
a proxy authorization header for the
request
and then it has the URL which is made
with the endpoint and port
and that then goes into the request dot
meta
so let's go ahead now and in our
settings fill out our proxy user
password endpoint and port
so let me just go here
and add them in now
so username password endpoint and Port
so I just need to change the password
obviously your username and password are
going to be whatever you guys have made
in your own dashboards with smart proxy
I'm just copying my details from here
and that looks fine so I should be able
to save that
and the next thing I need to do is to
make sure my middleware is enabled so
again
going to my
downloader middlewares
and I'm going to add in my
new
middleware
so I can add that in there and save it
the next thing we want to do is try and
run our spider again and see does it
work but we will obviously remove
what we did a second ago
so that we can show it's all going via
r
new middleware
so let's just
remove that
save it
and then
try run or spider again
and it looks like the
book details are coming through again so
I'm just going to close my spider
now we can have a look at smart proxy
and see
the
traffic usage
and as you can see
weave requests coming through
so there you go
we've got the user
and we've got our
usage by gigabyte
so
it's working just
as we wanted it to work
our requests are going through the
inspired proxy endpoint smart proxy is
looking after the IP address rotation
and it is sending us back the request
then scrapey is able to take the
information out of the HTML and we have
the data that we need
I think that's given you a very good
overview of how
we would use proxy port endpoints
so there's just one last thing I wanted
to show you guys which is
proxy API endpoints
so this is if you want to go just a step
further and not have to deal with
the browser headers are the user agents
or any things like that and maybe you
are scraping something which requires a
headless browser to do JavaScript
running for you
we can get that by using a proxy API so
again it's a service where there's an
endpoint we're sending our request
through that service and then that
service is making sure that certain
things are enabled to make sure that the
request gets us the page data
so what we're going to do is we are
going to
show you how to use that now
and that is also going to be a paid
service
and you can sign up for that by going to
scrapeups.io clicking get free account
signing up for it you've got
a thousand free credits there and if you
then once you're logged in
go to the proxy aggregator page go to
the request Builder
and you then have an API
key which you can use and you've got the
proxy endpoint which you can use as well
in your spider
so once you've got your API key we can
move back to our book Spider
file and we will start adding in a new
function which will help us send the
traffic first to our new proxy provider
so this new function is going to be
called get underscore proxy underscore
URL and we're going to pass in a URL to
that function
and then we're going to have an API key
as part of this payload object and
we're obviously going to put in
an API key where we
have our own API key that we got from
scrape UPS so I'm going to add mine in
quickly now
I'm just going to copy and paste that in
and
that then is going to slot in here this
payload is going to get URL encoded so I
need to import this URL encode from URL
lib and then it's going to create this
new proxy URL and then it's going to
return that proxy URL so this function
is going to
get the URL of the site that we want to
scrape and it's going to encode it along
with our API key and it's going to send
it to this API endpoint
once we've got that function created the
next thing we want to do is we want to
add it in
to where we use
our current scrapey Dash request
function so we will have URL is equal to
and then get proxy URL and then the same
down here
we'll be doing get proxy URL
with our next page URL to and the only
other thing we need to add in now
is
a new function called start requests
so we'll add this in under our custom
settings
and
I'll explain now what this does so
scrapey looks for this function when you
start up your spider if you don't have
it it doesn't need it to run it'll work
off of your start URLs list here but if
you do have it it will go in and work
off of what you have in here
so what I've asked it to do is I'm
saying okay when the spider starts up
run this function
and inside this function run our guess
proxy URL the same as we do down here
because we want the very first URL to
also go to our proxy so if we didn't
have this function in here what would
happen is that the very first URL would
actually not be sent to our proxy
provider endpoint URL so that would mean
that there's a chance that the first
very first request would get blocked
so that's why we have this function so
that the very first URL is properly
encoded and sent off using this get
proxy URL and once so that's where we
have start URLs and we're taking the
first string inside of our start urls
and then we're doing the Callback is
going to be our parse function and then
it's going to go on and it's going to
work perfectly because it'll be going
through get proxy URL for the rest of
the
requests as well
so that takes care of the very first
call and this get proxy URL function get
takes care of making sure that all the
requests are going to go via this proxy
API endpoint so then the request will
come back with the response and the
response will be able to be parsed in
our parse book page like it was before
so we should be able to go ahead and run
that
if we just do scrapey crawl book Spider
again
and
run this
oh there's one other thing so it just
did one request and stopped straight
away and that's because it's a very easy
mistake to make the allowed domains does
not contain our proxy dot scrapups.io so
let's just add that in
and
if we rerun it it should
there you go so we just close our spider
and I'll show you that we have all the
data is coming through so we've got our
product type books
the title
the description it's all there
so that's working perfectly
it's going via our proxy API endpoint
and the next I want to do is I want to
show you guys how instead of integrating
this directly into our spider we can use
a proxy middleware
that's been created especially by scrape
UPS so we can just quickly pip install
it and it makes things a bit easier if
you are adding it to a project and you
don't want to have to add this special
get proxy URL function
so what we would do in this case is
we would just pip install and then our
new python module scrape up stash
scrapey Dash proxy SDK and install that
and then the next thing we would want to
do is we would go to our settings and
like we always do add more settings
so let's just go down here
and add in the settings we want so it
would be again our API key
if the scriptop's proxy is enabled yes
and we'd be adding this line to our
downloader middleware
so I already have downloader middlewares
so I'm just going to add it here
so if I save that
and I add my API key
from here into my settings
okay so I just wanted to hear perfect
and I should just remove
the get proxy URL
from the places that we've been using
that function because we don't need it
anymore
and then it should run fine going
through our
middleware
so let's try and run that one more time
and see does it work going by the scrape
UPS proxy middleware
and it looks like
you have lots of requests going through
so if I just cancel that
and we can check
in our
dashboard
if we have
so we have 123 requests so that looks
like they all went to our books to
scrape.com site
so we have 123 requests made so it's
working like it should
so that makes it very easy if you want
to get started with it all you need to
do is do that pip install
and scrape UPS Scrappy Dash proxy SDK
add to
the two lines in here and the one line
into your downloader middlewares
and then it will just send all your URLs
via the scrape UPS proxy endpoint
now obviously you can make your own
custom download or middleware as well
and like we did for our smart proxy
example
that might be a bit more complex than
needs be for for this because there's
already the middleware that you can just
pip install
so we will leave the example with our
downloader middleware in our article so
if you want to check out a long version
of how to implement the downloader
middleware using the scrape UPS proxy
API endpoint we'll have that in our
article and you can copy and paste that
into your code and play around with that
so there's just one other thing if you
wanted to add some more and
functionality to the scrape-ups proxy
endpoint you could add in
for example the following so scrape Ops
underscore proxy underscore settings is
equal to Country us so this would send
all the traffic
via US IP addresses so
if you're for example scraping an
e-commerce website that needed to be
only loaded via the US so we'd show us
items only you would do something like
this country
us in your scriptops underscore proxy
underscore settings
they also have other functions such as
you can pass in if you wanted to be the
page to be JavaScript rendered and
there's many other different parameters
that you can pass in which will mean
that certain things are switched on on
your proxy provider site
so that way instead of you having to do
all this stuff on your side the proxy
provider will take care of it as long as
you pass in the correct parameters
and each proxy provider will have their
own page with all the different
parameters that they allow you to pass
in to them
okay so that's everything I wanted to
cover in
part nine
in part 10 11 and 12 we'll be looking at
how you deploy so basically get your
spiders to run on a on a server in the
cloud
so how you deploy the code to your
server in the cloud and then how you can
schedule and run your spiders to scrape
at certain times of the day or the week
so you can collect data on a periodic
basis without having to have everything
running off of your home so we're going
to go through some different options
there what's available we're going to
look at some open sourced options free
options and paid options and just have a
look at the different uis and give you a
bunch of different options and we'll go
through the pros and cons of why you
should pick one service over another
service and we look at how complex and
easy they are to use as well so that's
what we'll be doing in the next three
sections okay
see you in the next part 10 News
so in part 10 we're going to look at the
different tools we can use to deploy and
schedule our spiders online and the
tools we can use to monitor how well our
jobs are doing how much data is being
scraped and if we're missing any Pages
or items when we are actually running
our spiders
so you might be asking yourselves what
is this deployment in scheduling so
deployment is basically us putting the
spider that we've just created onto a
server that's always going to be online
so that we don't have to have our own
machine our own laptop or computer
running 24 7 at home we can just put
that onto a virtual machine somewhere on
cloud and then we can actually schedule
it to run at a certain point of time
once a week once a day once every hour
once every minute however often we want
to run our spider to collect the data
so that's the deployment is the act of
getting the spider on the machine and
the scheduling is scheduling to run at a
certain time of day or time of week and
then the monitoring is just seeing how
well our scraping is doing either seeing
have the jobs actually completed did the
Spider Run correctly did the Spider Run
for the correct amount of time that we
thought it was going to run for did it
get all the pages that we thought it
should be getting obviously if you see
Zero Pages script you know there's an
issue
so that's where the monitoring comes in
and it's very important that we do have
some monitoring setup because obviously
if you don't your spider can be running
every day and you could be missing huge
amounts of data
so that's deployment scheduling and
Mantra that's the first part we're going
to do in this part 10 is we're just
going to look at the different tools
available we look at free tools open
source tools and paid tools
so the first is square PD which is free
and open sourced anyone can download it
and contribute to it as well on GitHub
so the pros of this are it's obviously
free and open source there's
plenty of third-party libraries for it
as well there is optional uis from
different providers
and the downsides to it are things like
you need your own server ideally because
if you're running it on your own
computer or laptop you would have to
have your computer laptop online at all
times if you want to have this for
example running something every day at a
set time
so it also doesn't actually have a
scheduler so some of the other tools we
look at such as using scraps or scrapey
Cloud there with those tools you can
actually set a scheduled job to run at a
specific time every day
but with Scrapy D you'd have to use this
Cron job to hit the API endpoint to get
scrapey to run your job at a specific
time so Scrapy D is good because it's
free and open sourced but the downside
is there's a bit more configuration it's
a bit harder to install but we'll show
you exactly how to install it if you
want to install it
so the second option just using scrape
Ops to deploy a schedule and monitor
your jobs the upsides of data is it's
got a good a UI interface to use
simple to use and understand it's got
built-in monitoring for your jobs and
spiders it's easy to schedule stuff but
the downside would be you'd need your
own server as well like with square PD
and the third option with scrapey cloud
is it's a paid service they have a
freemium kind of version so you can just
check it out if you want with that it's
easy to set up you can just download
their CLI tool use that to deploy your
spider into their Scrappy cloud service
and then once it's deployed there you
can quickly and easily run it and you
don't need to have your own server set
up with another third-party provider
so they're the three main options we're
going to look at
scrapeyd
scrape ups and Scrappy cloud
so let's first off have a look at
scrapeyd
and then we look at two different UI
dashboards that we can install so we
don't have to control everything using
their API endpoints because well that
can be useful for some people most
people want to interact with their
spiders and run them and schedule them
using a nice front-end UI
okay so Scrapy D is available to
download as I said we need a third-party
server set up first to install scrapeyd
on so we're going to go ahead and create
that with digitalocean now so
digitalocean is a server provider which
enables you to quickly set up virtual
machines and then install everything you
need on them so you can also use any
other VM provider such as
vulture for example these are another
good provider and they have very cheap
servers as well
so
if you go off and create your own
account with vulture or digitalocean or
AWS go off create your virtual machine
I'm going to do that right now with
digitalocean and if you want to use this
you can just follow the steps that I'm
using so you just log in
go up to the create click droplets
select the country or region you want to
select it usually works best when you
select a region that you're close to
select Ubuntu for the operating system
version 22.10
we can select
the cheapest virtual machine they have
available which if you just click basic
and then go to regular for the SSD type
and then they have a four dollar a month
server there
so once you've selected the server you
want
you can either add an SSH key or a
password to log in that's not that
important now because for this you can
also log in Via their console which can
be accessed via the browser so that's
how we're going to do everything now
we're just going to use the browser to
log into the machine and install
everything we need makes it very simple
and easy to use
so that's all we need to do
once we get to the bottom we just click
create droplet and that will go ahead
and create the droplet for us
the droplet is just their term for
virtual machine I can see it's
creating
so I just give it a minute or two to
finish creating and then we can access
the console over here
so as you can see the droplets being
created now
we can click the console button which
will open up
a new window for us where we can access
the console and type in all the
instructions to get everything installed
correctly
so as you can see we're logged in to the
virtual machine and now we can start
running our commands
so first things first is we want to run
sudo apt update that just updates all
the packages on the machine to make sure
everything we install will be the most
up-to-date versions of things
so we'll give that a second to run
that's finished and the next thing we
want is to install python pip so we can
pip install all the packages we need for
python
so that's just sudo
apt install Python 3 Dash pip
this Command right here
we'll have all these commands easily
available for you to copy and paste from
our article as well so you don't have to
be pausing the video at every point in
time
Okay so ill office you ask do you want
to install this x amount of space will
be used we're just going to say yes
and sometimes it'll ask as well to
restart certain Services which we can
also say yes to
so while that installs I'm just going to
show you the project that we're going to
be using so the project is the part 6
code so obviously you may or may not
have done that part if you haven't you
can just git clone our project from here
and just type git space clone space this
URL so that this is the project that
we're going to be using from part six of
this course
okay so let's see is
wait it's just asking us to restart the
services
and now we'll go ahead and get clone our
project so as I said it's just git clone
and then the free code Camp Dash part-6
so that's installed
we'll now just see the into our project
and we will install a virtual
environment
using pip install virtualenf
so that's after installing virtual EnV
now we can actually create our own
VN folder where all the python packages
can be installed into
so we'll do that with virtual ends vnf
and as you can see this folder has been
created
so now we just need to activate it
so we do that with Source vnf bin
activate
it's activated now
and now we can install the project
requirements
so
this requirements.txt file contains all
a list of all the things we need to get
this project running so we can just do
pip install space Dash r space
requirements.txt and it'll go ahead and
install all the
packages that are needed to run the
project correctly
so we just
give it a minute or two to install
everything and then we should be able to
run our scrippy spider
next thing we do we just CD into our
book scraper
and we'll see if we can run scrapey list
so that ran correctly
and now we can run scrapey crawl book
Spider
so if we run that
should see Scrapy starting up and as you
can see
all our pages are being scraped
so our pages are being scraped and the
data is being extracted from the page
just like we were doing in part six
so that's perfect we don't have to wait
for that to run and complete the next
thing we're going to look at is how we
can install scrape PD
okay so we just pip install scrapeyd
to install that
and then the next thing we can do is
just run scrapeyd so to do that it's
just Scrapy D now I've added on a bit
extra after it just Scrapy D because I
want all the output that usually gets
displayed to the screen to go into this
scrapeyd logs.txt file
so put all the logs into scripty
logs.txt and run this command in the
background
so we can go ahead and do that and now
let's check that it's actually up and
running so to do that we will be using
curl to Ping the Damon status dot Json
endpoint that lets us know if Scrappy D
is running correctly so when we run that
command
it says status is okay there is zero
jobs pending zero jobs running zero jobs
finished because obviously we've just
ran Square PD we haven't run any spiders
yet
we have scripted setup
we can hit the end point using curl
the next thing we want to do is we want
to package up our spider
and then deploy it to scrapeyd because
if we don't do that square PD will not
have access to our project and will not
be able to run the spider
so to do that we can install scrapeyd
client
so again using pip we just do pip
install
Scrapy D client
that will go off and install the
scrapeyd client
the next thing we need to do is we need
to
go into our
scrapey.cfg file
so that should be
here this guy
scrapey.cfg so we want to edit that we
can use
Vim or VI
and we can
all we need to do for this is just
uncomment out this line so that it
deploys it to
Scrapy D which is running on localhost
Port 6800
so it's handy it's already there all we
have to do is go in
comment that out
so to save this
we just I'll show you one second
we just type in
the double dots to get up
so we can actually save it correctly and
then WQ exclamation
enter and that saves it
so
now that it's saved
we can do a scrape Ed deploy
and default is the name I've just picked
for the project
because scrapeyd works with the concept
of projects
so it needs a project name and then as
you can see it's deployed okay
and it now has
one spider available so we can now
go ahead and run our spider right now
again using curl so curl it's going to
hit this localhost
6800 port and the forward slash
schedule.json endpoint
we're adding the project name of default
and the spider name of book Spider
so because we've deployed it we should
be able to run this
and
it comes back with a job ID if it has
run correctly so it said status okay and
we're giving you back a job ID to show
that the job has been started now this
doesn't mean that it finished running so
if there is ever issues sometimes you
need to do further investigation
so
we've gone through how to use Scrapy D
and Scrapy D deploy to package up and
deploy our spider to scrape Ed and then
how we can use Curl to schedule our
spider using the curl command followed
by the schedule
endpoint so obviously if you wanted to
just run this yourself you could just
set up a cron and using your crown you
could say schedule this to run every day
at whatever time you want and then you
would just be running this command
obviously we want to make this easier
for people to use
so now we're going to look at the two
dashboards that we can install
the first being Scrappy dweb
and The Following being the scrape pups
Scrapy D integration
so
for scrape edweb scripted web is also a
third party open sourced application
that you can install
and we're going to go ahead now and
install that
so I'm just going to go back up to the
top level
that we were at and
just pip install
and then the Scrapy d-web
so that's going to go ahead and install
that
now
it may need a certain
specific version of specific packages to
be installed so I've gone ahead and
found out that
when I was making this video that four
specific packages needs to be installed
with a specific version number are the
installation wouldn't go and work
correctly on the version that of Ubuntu
operating system that we're using right
now
so it's easy enough all we're going to
do is specify
for four different packages the version
that we need
so the first one is just flask SQL
Alchemy
so we're just going to pip install that
specific version
the next is
we're going to do pip install SQL
Alchemy
then we're just going to install a
specific version of flask
and finally we're going to pip install a
specific version of work zoic
once those are all installed we can now
check and see the scripted web
run correctly so we need to do is type
in scrippity web
okay it's giving us an issue is it
let's just try and rerun
scripted web again
yeah so this time it ran correctly so
I think it just needed to create the
settings file initially
so you can you know it's running
correctly when it stays up and you have
the URLs where you can access it showing
here so we can just go ahead
and copy the URL that it has given us
so this is the IP address of our server
which you can also get in the
digitalocean dashboard followed by 5000
which is the port that scrippy web is
running on if we copy that go up paste
that into a browser
we should see
the scrapery web dashboard showing up
correctly
so
we can see the jobs that I've already
run
so we can see the job that was run
earlier that we ran when we ran it
manually via the command line we had the
default project and the spider book
Spider and the job ID that was returned
to us
so
it doesn't have the pages and the items
because it needs this log parser
module to be installed so we're going to
go ahead install the log parser so we
can see the pages and items and more
statistics and we're also going to add
in a username and password just some
basic authentication right now anyone
can hit this endpoint and start running
my jobs I don't want that to be
happening and I'm pretty sure you guys
don't either so you're paying for the
server you don't want anyone to be able
to come on and start messing around with
your dashboard so we're going to quickly
go and do that now
so we'll start by just copying and
pasting this pip install log parser
command
I'm just going to shut down scrape
Beauty web for a second
so
run pip install log parser
then once that's installed I want to
edit my scriptd web settings
so I can use
VI again
and I'm going to first enable the off
so as you can see here it's currently
set to false
I'm going to set it to true
and then I'm going to set a username of
test
and a password of one two three four
five six seven eight obviously set
better username and passwords than that
please for your own projects
and your own servers the next thing we
need to do is come to our script e
servers list
and just comment out
this line here
because we don't have a server running
on Port 6801 we just have our Square PD
running on
this
Port 6800 on localhost
so once that's done
the next thing to do is to add in our
logs directory and to enable the log
parser here
so let's just enable the loud parser by
setting that to true
true and for us
the
directory is going to be
just root then the name of the project
frequent Camp part 6 and the name of
these spiders the folder containing the
spider which is book scraper and then
it's got a logs folder in there which is
where the log parser is going to read
the logs from
so obviously if you've got a different
project name and a different spider name
you need to just make sure that that is
correct
but it will always have a folder in
there with logs already so just find out
where your logs folder is and paste in
the directory here
and then the last thing we need to do is
just set our scripted server which is
just the default again which you can see
from above
127.0.0.1 is usually the default and
it's running on Port 6800 so now that we
have all that I'm just going to save the
file
and now that is saved
we should be able to run
scripted web again
this time I'm going to do like I did
with scrape Ed and get the logs to save
into a separate log file so they're not
coming up on the screen
and I'm going to run it on the
background
so that should be running we can check
if everything is running correctly using
the following using the sudo SS command
so we can see
that we have scrape PD running on Port
6800 of localhost
and we can see that Scrapy web is
running on localhost Port 5000.
so we can see both of them are running
we can see the ports they're running on
and we have
the process ID which we can use to kill
the process so if we wanted to stop one
of them from running for example I might
as well just stop Scrapy D from running
and show you guys
you can just type in Kill and then we
will get the scrappy D process ID from
here
and we will just paste that in and press
enter
and then you guys can see that
Scrapy D is no longer running so that is
how you can kill them if they're running
in the background as a process like that
so I'll just start up Scrappy D again
so if we check
we should see Scrapy D running and
scripted web running
perfect okay so because we killed and
restarted Scrapy D we need to just
re-deploy our project again using the
Scrapy D deploy because if we go back to
our Scrapy dashboard we won't be able to
see our spider
and we won't be able to run our spider
so we need to package up and redeploy
the project again
so we can just do that with square PD
deploy
so it's just Scrappy Dash deploy and
we're just picking the project name of
default again
so that'll just package up our spider
and add it again to scrippy D
so that's been added again and we can go
back to our endpoint now it asks us to
sign in so if I try and sign in it says
no you need to add in the username and
password so
I'll add in my username and password
that I set in the config file
and sign in
if I go to run spider
we can then see the default
default latest version
book Spider
if you need to set any specific settings
and Arguments for your project you can
do it there if you want to set it to run
at a specific day of the week
hour our minute you can do it here
so I'm not going to set it for a
specific time in the future I want it to
run right now the next thing I need to
do is Click just check command
that will paste in a default command
which as you can see here is just going
to do the curl
to the endpoint that we did earlier so
all scripted web is doing is running
this command so everything is correctly
set the project the version The Spider
and we just want it to run switch click
run spider and that's going to go off
and kick off our s our job and it's
going to start running
so that should be running now and we
should soon be able to see the
statistics coming back for a number of
pages and items
so let's give that a minute or two to
run
so as you can see it has finished
and it took 24 seconds to run and you
can see some other
stats and pieces like that now we're
still missing the pages and items and
this sign is still up here saying that
we need to install loud parser so I
think I might have actually put in the
incorrect path to where the logs are
stored so let's fix that and then we can
show you how the pages and items show up
so if we go back
I've discovered that I need to change my
path in the scripty web settings
so I can open up my scripty web settings
so here you go so
I think we just need to fix this so as I
said depending on your project you just
need to find where the log folder is
kept so I think that should do it it's
just forward slash root forward slash
Frankel cam part six and then locks so
I'm just going to save that
and I'm going to restart
scrivity web unless it's after fixing
itself but I think we need to restart it
yep so just go back
run the sudo
ss-t-u-n-l-p command again and we will
kill our scripty web
using the kill command
and we'll run scriptyweb again
so yep so as you can see
the log parser ran eight seconds ago
and it was last updated
at this time
so if we re-run our
spider
we're going back to run spider
and
we'll put the default project the latest
version book Spider put in the command
run spider and it'll run again
in the meantime it's gone through and
it's parsed the last logs that we ran a
couple of minutes ago and you can see
the pages and items have actually been
populated here so it scraped 1051 pages
and there was a thousand items and we
can see some more stats by clicking the
stats button
so you can see
what else to have warnings and errors so
there's one warning and you can see the
latest item that was scraped and as we
can see it was this URL
this was the book title
we can see the price tax and all the
other stuff that we've already selected
in part five and six so
this is kind of the basics of scribdy
web and how you would install the
scribby web dashboard to work with
scrapyt
obviously you can also
see the full logs
and you know
if you need to
see exactly a specific error or you need
to nail down further into the logs
you've got the full logs available there
as well
and it's picked out the warnings and if
there was any errors it would show them
as well so it's very handy it's free
it's open sourced you can install it
yourself
and as you can see there's a bit of
configuring in the settings and there's
a little bit more knowledge required
into okay you need to deploy this
project like this you need to run the
spider like that
there is some help pieces as well
available for example if you forget how
to deploy it they do have a help section
here and you can
follow the instructions as to oh how do
I deploy my project so that scripty web
and Scrappy D can use it again they've
got the commands you need to run here
and the steps you need to follow are you
can put in your project directory and
they can Auto package it up
using scriptyweb as well so
the next dashboard we look at is the
scrape UPS integration with scrapeyd so
there's two different dashboards for
scrapeyd Scrapy web and the scraps
dashboard
so
for that you need to go off and create a
scrape UPS account so you can just go to
scrapeups.io
and if you've been using it for any of
the other parts we've gone through
already in our course you can use the
existing API key you have if you're just
joining us for this section you can sign
up register for free and get your own
API key
so you will just need the API key
and then you will just need to follow
the monitoring steps so
we'll just click monitoring it should be
scrapey
so I need to do pip install scrape up
and we'll do pip install scrape up stash
scrapey
so we've installed the scrape off SDK we
just need to add our API key to the
scrapey project settings
so
I can copy this line
go now into
my folder
and
I want to edit my settings.py file
and I'm going to just add
the API key in
here
and check what else I need to install I
also need to install
the extension and the downloader
middlewares
so
go
down to my
downloader middlewares
and
I'll add those in here
so
copy that
paste that in
and
to the extensions
I'll just put that under the existing
extensions there
so
paste that in as well so we've got the
download the Download Remember words the
extension and the API key
so I should be able to now save that
and
just check that there's nothing else to
do there
I think that's all correct so that's to
install the monitoring so everything
will show up in the dashboard but we now
want to install the actual
scheduling side of things so for that we
will go to the
servers and deployments section
and we will
add a new Scrapy d
server so we just need the name of our
server
we just do test
obviously you can name your server
whatever you want we need the server IP
address so
we will go to
our digitalocean
dashboard and copy the IP address here
so the ipv4 so copy that
and
just need to paste that in
and save the details
and then
it's saying you should sh into your
server we're already in on our console
and it says run the command in your
terminal so we will copy this command
and go back to our console
and I'll just go back up to
the top
and paste that in
it's installing
everything it needs it might need to
restart some Services again we can say
yes to that
once it's finished we will say yes to
that and okay so everything seems to be
finished
so we can now
go back and check our
servers list and we can see our server
name is there and it's connected
and we can
check our server perfect so if we need
to edit or delete the details there and
it says your server is now set up
correctly you can schedule your jobs on
the scheduler page here I'll click that
and click schedule job
and I have my server name
I've got my spider book Spider
I will run the spider now and I can
click if I wanted to run it every
month every day all I can select
you know a specific month or whatever
we'll do that in a second
for now I just want to run it now and I
don't have any settings and arguments to
add in so I can submit the job and the
job is scheduled
so
in a few seconds that should
show up in the jobs list
in the meantime let's go and schedule
a job to run let's say once a week
so let's say
every Monday
at
7am
and obviously that's in UTC time zone
crons are usually run in UTC
so you need to make sure that that
corresponds to your own time zone
correctly so we're saying every Monday
at 7am
please run the book spider spider
on the test server
and if we submit that
it should then show up in our list so
there you go at 7am only on Mondays
it'll run that's very useful if you need
to set up your spider to run every day
every hour or whatever you can
View and edit them here and you can
enable them disable them
so if we go back to our dashboard
we don't have any details coming through
yet
there might have been an issue with
running it as well
but we'll explore that now so when there
is an issue like this where we can't see
any data coming into a dashboard the
best thing to do is to try and just run
the scrapey list are the square B crawl
command manually from our server so I'm
just going to go back to
the console and go back into the project
and
from inside
the free code Camp part 6 book scraper
folder I'm going to run a scrapey list
first
and if there's an issue with scrapey or
there is an issue with the settings
it'll show up here
so
Scrappy list
and we have an error
escape the error and scrape is saying
that there is an indentation error in
the downloader middleware so that's
probably what's causing the issue
so we can just
uh
edit that
so open up our settings again
and check
it's a download middlewares so I think
it's just
that there is a space here
and in case it's also this guy I'll just
remove the indentations there and do the
same for the extensions and then
hopefully
there's no more issues
so save that and try run scripture list
again
at this time it worked and book spider
is returned perfect so if we go back to
our scrapups dashboard
and try and run that again
so it's got the server and splatter we
need selected
and we can submit job
so this time
within hopefully a couple of seconds
it's just
go back to our servers page and go back
to our jobs page we can see it's now
running so it's after kicking off
at 6 23.
I'm going to give that a couple of
seconds to run and then we should also
have the stats available for
this job
so we can see on Monday
one job run
and it's in the middle of running now
so we'll give it a couple of seconds to
run and then we should see
things like the runtime the pages missed
Pages items
and all the other stats coming through
okay so on our jobs page now we can see
that the status is changed to finished
it took 25 seconds and
we can see the number of pages items
coverage
and everything there so we can actually
click into that now and we can see all
the pages scrape there
the runtime and everything in more
detail
so we also have things like number of
items
fields that were scraped so this pulls
in stuff like the we can see if there
was any stuff that was missed
so things like the number of stars the
price everything most things seem to be
at 100 percent
and obviously the description there
there was one or two descriptions that
were missed for some reason so this is
can be useful to see which Fields were
missed are which Fields came through
correctly you can also see the amount of
bandwidth that was used
and we can see that there was one
warning as well
so obviously when you have
multiple runs of the same spider then
you can actually compare
if you're running this daily you could
compare the stats every day and then if
on one day suddenly you see a major
Divergence in the stats you can say okay
there must be an issue with my spider I
need to investigate and go in and
investigate further
so
that's very useful we also have the
status codes if there's 500s coming back
are 404s the page isn't found so maybe
they the links are broken so you can use
these status codes as well to diagnose
any other issues
so that's how you would use the scrape
UPS dashboards to integrate in with
Scrapy D which would also be running on
your server
so you've two different dashboards that
you can use with scrapeyd scriptyweb are
the script UPS dashboard and integration
if you guys have any other questions
with that you can stick it in the
comments as well
so in the next section we'll be looking
at how we can
instead of using scrapeyd
to
degrade with scrape UPS we'll be looking
at using the complete scrape UPS
integration
to integrate in directly with your
scrapey project instead of using scrape
PD as a kind of a middle layer which
gets integrated with your project and
then other things have to integrate in
and hit the API endpoints this just goes
directly and integrates with your server
and your project so that's what we'll be
looking at in part 11 and then Part 12
we'll be looking at using the scrapey
cloud
so that's it for now and see you in part
11.
so in part 11 of the scrappy beginners
course we're going to be looking at
using scrape UPS to manage deploy and
monitor our spiders
so we'll jump straight into it first
things first we're going to need to set
up a virtual machine so you can do it
with AWS if you already have an account
with them you can do it with
digitalocean most of these different
companies have free credits so you can
just sign up use their free credits try
it out and then go from there
so I've already got a digitalocean
account and I'm going to be using that
so you guys can follow along with that
are you guys if you already have an AWS
or Azure account you can follow on from
the step where we log in to the actual
virtual machine
so I'm just going to quickly set up a
server here I'm going to go on to the
cheapest ones they have which are four
dollars a month
and I think that's all I need to select
so I can just create droplets
now that the droplets been created I
have the dashboard available where it
shows things like the IP address and a
few different graphs
I'm just going to
open the console now
so that's going to open up a new window
and it's going to
SSH onto a machine and then we can then
run commands on our virtual machine
so while that's getting set up if you
guys haven't already
set up a account with scrape UPS so you
can get a free account there and we'll
be using them now to integrate with our
server
so go ahead create an account I have one
already set up
once your account is set up
go to servers and deployments on the
site
where it says add servers click add
and then we're going to name our server
free code camp
and we're going to put in the IP address
of the server
so we get that from here
copy their P address
paste it in save the details
and now it says to
provision a server we need to run this
script on our server so we copy the
details there go in to our terminal our
console for the server
and
paste in
the script details so that's going to go
off run the script and provision the
server
and
we can see that it is running through
installing the dependencies it needs
installing a new user and the authorized
keys and installing the required
libraries so that's just going to run
through those different steps
and once it's complete we should be able
to then go on and in Clone our
spider onto our server using the
dashboard so that can take an integer
two we let it just run through the
different steps
so now our provisioning has completed
and it's brought us into the server
dashboard and here we have options like
clone repository add spider delete the
server edit the details schedule jobs
and the SSH keys for the server so we're
going to go ahead and go to the Clone
Repository
that's where it's going to be getting
the details of the repository that we
paste in and then it's going to clone
the spider directly onto our server so
we don't need to actually do it manually
ourselves we can do it through this UI
here
so for that we're going to first
go to the free code comp part 6 that
we've been using in the part 10 video so
we're going to use part six and the next
thing you want to do is you want to Fork
your own copy obviously if you have your
own spider and you're using that that's
fine if you're following along with me
now the best thing to do is Fork your
own copy so click the four button follow
the steps that's just going to copy over
the free code cam part 6 onto your own
repo and then from there like I have
here I've just done it myself I now have
it under my own name and in here the
next step will be to add the
deploy key so this deploy key will
enable us to do commands like git clone
and pull the repo directly from our
GitHub onto the machine
so we just need to add that key we go to
settings deploy keys
add deploy key
I'm going to call this
free code cam VM and I'm going to paste
in my deploy key so you get this deploy
key in here you copy that
you add it in here
remove any spaces and we don't need to
allow right access for the moment
because we're just going to be pulling
and we can add the key
so once the key is added
we can then go back to our main UI here
the next thing we need to do is
just go and grab our URL
from the main page here
grab our URL
so this is my repository and this is my
own copy of the free code cam part 6.
the branch name
is main so you can see it here it's Main
so I need to make sure to put in the
right Branch name and then the language
is Python and the framework is scrapey
so that's all correct
so this is the install script that's
going to run
when we click on repo it's going to go
in to our virtual machine it's going to
then get clonus and then once it's get
cloned the repo it's going to go into
the repo install a python virtual
environment activate the virtual
environment and then install the modules
that are in the requirements.txt so if
you
look in here it's going to install the
different modules that are listed in
here
which is everything that the project
needs to run
so
once it's done that it's just going to
make sure that scrape is installed and
while we're at it we're going to add the
monitoring module first grade pops as
well so let's just add in
that here as well so install scrape up
scrape B which installs the monitoring
python module for us so once that's all
in here we can click clone repo and it's
going to go through the steps here so
it's cloning the repo great
and then it's going to run the install
script which can take two or three
minutes
and then the next step is it's going to
find the Scrapy spiders by running the
scrapey list command
so I'm just going to give it a minute or
two and then we will hopefully see our
repo in our table here and we'll see the
spider our book spider in under the
spiders table on the right so as you can
see the install script ran correctly and
it was able to find our spiders as well
so you can see our spider automatically
came in here and here is our cloned
Repository
so if you click in you can see that
there is
a deploy script here as well so if you
need to deploy updates to your code
you will
update your own repository and then for
the code to actually go onto the server
you just need to go in here and click
deploy and it will then pull the latest
from your Repository
so that's how you would update the code
on your VM
okay so we have a repository we have our
spider so let's just go ahead and show
you guys you can quickly run the Spider
by just clicking the run now button
it'll go in select the server the
repository and the spider because you
could have multiple
spiders in your repository and we're
just going to click submit job to run it
straight away
so the job is started
and if you want to check the log
straight away you just come here and
click view logs
so you can see it's just gonna head and
it's running the spider correctly and
you can see the title product type price
everything is coming through so that's
how simple it is to run the spider
so the last step we want to do now is to
activate the monitoring for our spider
so instead of having to just look at a
bunch of logs in a log file like that we
can have everything displaying in the
dashboard like we had in part 10. so to
do that let's just open up the docs
go to monitoring
python scrapey
scrapey SDK integration
so we've already done this pip installed
scrape up scrapey as part of the install
script when we cloned our repository so
we don't need to do that again
but we do need to add in our API key and
the extension bits here
so it's telling us we need to add this
to our settings.py file in our scrapey
project
so let's go ahead and do that now
so I'm going to open up my Repository
go to book scraper and go to the
settings.py file and I can just edit it
directly in here
so
I'll need to add the
three different sections so first I'll
add the API key and then I'll go and add
the extension and the downloader
middlewares
so I'll just copy this line and go to
GitHub
paste this in
here I need to get my API key which I
can get
from my settings
here
paste in my API key
and then I want to go to my extensions
and then the general middlewares
extensions
are currently comforted out so I'll just
add it underneath
and last of all downloader middleware's
so obviously if you guys are using your
own spider that has
the downloader midwares uncommented out
and you're just adding these two lines
to your existing list but here because
it's currently commented out I'm just
pasting in the whole lot in together
so we've got the extensions the
downloader middlewares and the API key
so we should be able to just commit the
changes and now we can deploy the code
via our dashboard so now that's
completed
we go back to our server
go into our free code camp
server
go into our clone Repository
and click deploy here
so the latest has been deployed we can
check the log as well to see
did deployment work so we can see it
updated the book scraper settings.py
file one file changed with nine
insertions so that's perfect
great so now that that's in we should be
able to
run our book Spider again
submit the job
and
if we check the logs again
we can see it's
kicked off
and if we go to our
jobs list we can see there's one running
so this is the one we ran for part 10
and this is the one that is running now
so once it's completed running in about
20 more seconds we should see the pages
items coverage and everything else fill
in as well
and we can also see that in our
dashboard we can see
under Tuesday we have this job that is
running now
so we'll just quickly show you how you
can also schedule it
so
in case you're just joining us for part
11 if you want to schedule a job to run
on This Server recurring you just go and
click recurring
and then you can select we want okay
every day in March
we want every
every time at midnight we want this job
to run
so we'll submit the job
and then we can check in our scheduled
jobs
we have book Spider
which will run as 12 every day only in
March and there it is
so then if you need to edit that or you
want to just disable it you can go to
the scheduler Tab and you have the
ability just to disable it there or
delete it cloness view the logs whatever
you need to do
so if we just go back to our dashboard
we can now see that the job is completed
the page is scraper there we can see the
items are there and everything looks
like it ran correctly so we can compare
the the two days so yesterday this many
pages were scraped are this many status
codes came back today this many status
codes came back so it is useful if you
need to compare the same job that was
run over multiple days you can quickly
see okay if the runtime varied or if the
number of page varied varies are the
items are the coverage
you can see that very quickly in one
page one glance so that makes it very
useful
and if we need to drill down into the
individual job we can just click in and
we can delete the job data or do
anything else we need to do here
so
that brings us to the end of this
section
any questions you guys might have
let us know and I hope you have an idea
now of how to quickly get set up with a
virtual machine and hook it up to use
scrape UPS so a reminder that everything
that we've used with scrape UPS here is
free to use so there's no limitations on
the image of servers you can hook up are
the amount of jobs you can run
so that's the end of part 11 guys
so in part 12 we're going to look at
everything to do with Scrappy cloud
so Scrappy Cloud was made by the
developers of scrapey and it's a way
which you can deploy and run and
schedule your spiders on the cloud using
scrapey Cloud the great thing is you
don't need to have your own third-party
server so you don't need to have a
server with digitalocean or vulture or
AWS you can just deploy it directly onto
Scrappy cloud and just run it the only
downside is that if you want to schedule
your jobs it's paid so you can run your
jobs and it's free but to schedule your
jobs on Scrappy Cloud you have to sign
up for a monthly subscription
so we'll show you how everything works
and then between scrapey Cloud scrape
ups and Scrapy D you guys will have had
a full overview of all the different
ways you can deploy schedule and run
your spiders on the cloud and you can
decide then which kind of way you want
to go do you want to go with a
completely open source way with using
just scrapeyd and scripted web or do you
want to go with a free way using scrape
UPS or do you want to go with a paid
solution with scrapey cloud
so you'll have the full up array of
options covered by the time we finish
part 12. okay
so let's quickly look at scrapey Cloud
so scribby cloud is obviously made by
size the Creator is the scrappy scalable
Cloud hosting for your scrapey spiders
and that's pretty much what it is host
and monitor your Scrappy spiders in the
cloud as we said and it's very reliable
easy to scale as they say on demand
scaling they have lots of other
Integrations as well so
what we need to do is you need to go
ahead and create an account with them
once you have an account you can then go
into the dashboard and access scrapey
Cloud here on the side
so I'm just going to start a new project
and I'm going to call it just free code
camp
and
click Start
so
then it's got the instructions here of
what we need to do to install the
command line
tool so we can easily deploy our spider
into the scrapey cloud so first things
first we're going to go ahead and we're
going to be using the part 6 code
example again so the code that we used
for part six of this course we're going
to just get clone that so I've got an
empty folder here open in vs code and
I'm just going to Gig clone the free
code Camp part 6 and then I'm going to
quickly install
a virtual environment obviously if you
guys are on Windows or on Linux you guys
need to follow the steps they'll be
covered in part two of this course to
make sure you're installing the correct
virtual environment
for your operating system
and then once the virtual environment is
set up we can activate it
so just do
Source
bin activate
I know it's activated and now we can go
and follow the instructions here
so I'm just going to copy and paste them
in directly
so install S hub
and then to the s-hub login
and then it's just a matter of putting
in my API key
okay so that's all installed
put in s-hub login
it says I'm already logged in
I'll just log out to make sure that you
guys can see the full process
so a sub login
put in my API key from here
paste in
my API key obviously you guys will be
putting in your API key so please don't
use mine and then we can just do
s-hub deploy and it should deploy
if I'm in my
correct project so I'm inside my project
and I think it wants there to be a
scrapey.cfg file so you need to make
sure you're in the correct folder
and if it's correct it you can see
the deploying to Scrappy Cloud project
and then the project ID there
so in the meantime you can see it's
bills the project and then it
uploads it to the site here so here you
can see it's been deployed
and it's successful so if it works
correctly this should all
be very similar to what you see
so now that it's deployed into the cloud
we can go to our jobs dashboard
and we should be able to run
our spider
so we have our book Spider available now
in the drop down
and we can leave everything else the
same you've got priorities there if you
want to have certain jobs running ahead
of others so we can just click run
and that should kick off the book spider
and it should start scraping
our
books to scrape site so you can see it's
running away there
and
we should see that when it's completed
it'll be in the completed table
and it'll also have the items and the
requests and the errors all available
here as well so they'll start populating
in a second
so
as you can see three requests the logs
are there if we wanted to run every day
once a week periodically whenever we
want we just go to periodic jobs click
add periodic job
select the spider and then we can select
okay we want to run every Monday at
6am
or 7am
and
we can just select every day
or every Monday 7 A.M
and we can save that
so as you can see here it says
the periodic jobs below will not run
because I have not created a paid
subscription so you just need to click
subscribe now
and then sign up for the paid version
and then this job will run every Monday
at 7.
but if you guys just want to try it out
then you could just schedule the jobs
normally by clicking run here manually
yourselves
so
my spider is still running away
we'll just leave that complete and then
we'll have a look at the items and
requests and some of the stats that are
available
so as you can see our job is completed
with the Thousand items
the requests so the amount of pages that
were scraped and the logs so we can
click into the requests
and you can see T thousand requests if
you want so you can see all the specific
URLs that were scraped the statuses
etc etc
the items then are a bit more
interesting obviously because that's the
actual data that we scraped so we've got
everything set up nicely there our
prices taxes titles URLs description
etc etc
so you can check quickly if the
information that was scraped correctly
came through or not
if you need to look at the logs or the
stats that's also available there so
as you can see it's very polished very
nice simple to use and also works and
auto scales when you need to scale
things as well
so I think that's the ins and outs of
scrapey cloud I think now you should
have a very good idea of the different
options you have when it comes to
deploying your spiders and then
scheduling and running your spiders and
seeing all the stats in various
dashboards so just to go through the
three options you have first option
Scrapy D which can run just via an API
endpoint and you can hit the API
endpoint to schedule things and deploy
things
with Scrapy D you have two uis you can
use with it the
scrapeydweb are the scrape Ops
dashboards which
we've shown you how to install so that's
the free open source part the second
option was using scrape ups for
everything and using the scrape UPS
integration directly with a server such
as digitalocean are AWS our vulture so
you need to set up a VM quickly there
first
and then the final option was just using
the scrapey cloud for everything and
deploying it directly to Scrappy Cloud
but it was paid if you want to do any
sort of periodic jobs to schedule them
to run daily or weekly or whatever
so there are the three main options and
I'll leave it up to you guys to decide
what works best for you so that brings
us to the end of Part 12 and in part 13
we'll just go through everything and do
quick recap of the entire course
so see you in part 13 guys
so guys we've come to the end of our
Scrappy beginners course this is the
last part so we'll just do a quick wrap
up and then I'll give you a small bit of
an overview of some extra skills you
might find useful if you want to
continue on and get better at scraping
using scraping
so we've built an end-to-end scrapey
project that scrapes all the books from
books to scrape and then cleans the data
and stores the extracted data in
different file formats and different
places such as a database
we then looked at
optimizing our headers and user agents
so that websites would let us get
through any antibiot software that they
have on their site and we also looked at
how we can use proxies in the different
proxy provider options that are out
there if we want to have something
that's a little less Hands-On
and then finally we looked at how you
can deploy your spider
to the cloud onto a server and then how
you can schedule this to run
periodically and then how you can view
the results of your running spiders
but obviously that isn't everything
we've only gone through the kind of
Basics there's still a lot more
different edge cases that we haven't
covered and the number one thing is
probably scraping Dynamic websites so
there's a lot of websites out there that
are rendered in the browser so that
means that they're using a front-end
framework which will actually only
display the page once all the data is
received by the browser so in that case
if you were to ask for a URL what you
get back might not contain the data
you're looking for because it hasn't had
a chance to render inside in a browser
so
things I would recommend that you look
at in in those cases would be looking at
things like Scrappy Puppeteer or Scrappy
selenium which then use scrapey with a
headless browser integration to actually
render the website in a headless browser
so then that way using scrapey Puppeteer
or scrapey selenium you can actually
render the page and get the data you
need
the other option would be to find the
API endpoint because most of these sites
that are front and rendered have API
endpoints and you can find the data
there
so I'll just give you one example of
what it would look like to see the data
coming back from an API endpoint so I
would recommend if you guys want to work
through a couple of different challenges
site have put together this great site
which we've been using for our books to
scrape.com but they also have a bunch of
different other examples using this
quotes dot to scrape.com where you can
for example have infinite scrolling so
how would you get around a page where
you have infinite scrolling like
something like Instagram or Facebook and
you can practice having a JavaScript
rendered site so there's all these kind
of different options which you can
practice with and they have all these
different pages available here for you
to practice on so
one example would be
this one see we're scrolling down and if
you go to your network tab you can see
there is data being asked for every time
we scroll down so more pages of data are
being requested and they come back but
instead of it being HTML it comes back
as Json and then this Json data we've
got the quotes which then the front end
framework then goes off and populates
the page with
so
this is an example of where you can
actually
directly query an API endpoint instead
of actually scraping the HTML you can
ask for the API endpoint to give you
back the data directly so that even
makes your life easier
so this is one example of what I was
talking about if you come into contact
with a front-end rendered
page that gets rendered in the browser
so I really would recommend you guys
checking out and working your way
through these different challenges that
are available on the twoscribe.com site
now another very important thing is
obviously getting through a login
endpoint which we didn't do in this
course but which is something which a
lot of websites would have so that is
something as well I would really
recommend that you guys go off and
explore how to do
so the last major thing I think would be
looking at how you can scrape at scale
if you really want to imagine you're
scraping millions of pages a day you
know there's different ways which you
can use things like scrapey redis to use
redis to store all the URLs you want to
scrape in one central place and then you
could have multiple different servers
pulling URLs off this queue and then the
old URLs can be scraped by multiple
different worker machines at the same
time again this is all using scraping so
that is something I would highly
recommend you guys to look at as well if
you're interested in scraping at scale
now all this stuff we also have as
articles and videos so if you guys want
to check out some more videos and
in-depth articles I would recommend you
guys checking that out like we have
scraping behind logins and we have
separate articles on using Scrappy
Puppeteer Scrapy selenium
Etc
and also using scrapey redis if you want
to do a distributed worker architecture
so all that is up there for you guys if
you want to continue on your journey and
learn more about scrapey and the kind of
more challenging parts of using scrapey
to scrape the web
so I think that comes to the end of our
course I'd like to thank you for
following along and if you have any
questions just reach out put a comment
on the video and we'll do our best to
get back to you thanks guys